greetings the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you by Lending Tree
did you know that depending on where you
get your mortgage you could save $20,000
or more $20,000 or more but 80% of
people only get one mortgage offer and
if you go with your bank chances are
you'll get ripped off maybe screwed
Lending Tree doesn't want that to happen
so what we're gonna do is this are you
sure you have the best deal we'll find
out how much you could save today by
going the lemon Lending Tree coms last
Church again that's Lending Tree calm /
church Lending Tree LLC and MLS number
one one three six terms and conditions
apply but listen don't get ripped off go
to Lending Tree calm right now another
thing it's summertime the winter's
coming
the holidays are coming Thanksgiving
coming you're still lonely you know why
cuz you look like a Martha Vaughn
your underwear is he's still wearing
your tighty whities with skid marks and
they got that yellow stay in the front
who wants to be with you listen you want
to look good in your underwear and be
comfortable right but that perfect
balance is hard to find don't sacrifice
Tao or comfort check out me on these
calm and find out why the best pair
underwear why they're the best pair I'm
doing right now right now me and this is
an exclusive offer just for the church
family we're gonna give you 20% off your
first pair and free shipping and me on
these are so sure you'll love the
underwear don't give you on a percent
satisfaction guarantee you ordered pay
you don't love them you get a full
refund refund it's a no-brainer 20
percent off free shipping run a percent
satisfaction guarantee what the hell you
waiting for go to me on these calm right
now / Joey I get 20% off your first
order kick this another [ __ ] meal Lee
oh [ __ ] I want to see nothing but
[ __ ] and elbows is a church what's
happening now Wednesday Oh August 23rd
2017 get your [ __ ] together sounds like
a guy fighting his way out of a prison
rape we ain't [ __ ] around here
elbows and [ __ ] kick that melee oh
[Music]
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
again you filthy animals oh there's more
black people black people you understand
them voices that music anything could
happen
Church what's happened now you bad
[ __ ] Bert Kreischer my favorite
Christ killer Lisa n that's gonna be a
good one [ __ ] ready here here
you go
put your head down here we go Oh give it
to me
Oh open that little bet
so Churchill what's happened down how
bad of a jam is that I've [ __ ]
amazing
you know what's crazy she didn't do that
anymore live after she became a
born-again Christian oh because people
start [ __ ] in the audience right here
that song it was my dick about you at
the Yankee Ella
for you Yankee hat off for Christ is
here this evening it's a late podcast
but that's how we do it we got to put
the girls to sleep I didn't take the
girls swimming today she got promoted to
the higher class you John really you
know she sits in there for 30 minutes
and it's like a constant smile and every
10 minutes she looks over the watch of
you're watching them and you have to
give him a heads up yes and they go
[ __ ] bananas she got out when I take
him Peyton I took him turn they wanted
to go to [ __ ] Jersey mice
yeah she kept saying she want me all
this Alami restaurant which made me
think what the [ __ ] who's giving out
dick was it without stinky [ __ ]
Italian dick around here so we went in
there you know it's a real pleasure
especially where I came from you came
from a tight-knit family to be doing the
little things I do we go home we [ __ ]
go on the computer I make a typing
Smurfs and [ __ ] trolls it's better
for me we sit there and after 15 minutes
you look me straight in the face she
goes daddy and you leave now
like okay thanks for throwing me out of
my [ __ ] office yeah and that's it
that's that's my lights you just dress
with 15 minutes you know what take a
[ __ ] hike yeah and I bet you going
through the same thing at a different
level in your home
I said Allah said to me I said I said I
was working as she said she pulled me
aside in a room and goes hey who do not
work so much and I said now she goes no
I mean like is there a way for you to
like work one last day a week excuse
your working to every night and I feel
like I don't get to do things with you I
was like I know but that's kind of my
job happens at night and I try to do
stuff during the day I worked all day
today too and all night and then I said
okay I said don't worry I'm doing Joey's
podcast tonight but I'm not gonna get
picked up til 9:00 that's your bedtime
so we watched wreckit-ralph and I said
to her at 8:30 I said and that Joey may
come at like a 45 so just you know I
might have to leave early and I just
kind of rolled her eyes got real
frustrated then I and then you called
and you called right when the movie
ended I said Joey's outside now that
goes you held your promise I was like
yeah of course I didn't I put a left at
a 45 but they see what she talked about
on my podcast I was doing the intro to
my podcast this afternoon when she
walked in the man came and started
talking about on the podcast but yeah as
[ __ ] sucks they grow up and I said I
wish I had listened to you guys earlier
I think it was a mistake doing Travel
Channel as long as I did I needed to do
it cuz I needed the money and I enjoyed
the experience I had a great time but I
was gone for such long chunks that I
really missed out a lot of [ __ ] you know
what I mean and then the weakside off I
do stand-up and it was just burning it
at both ends I had a dad who worked at
night and yeah he wasn't there as much
but I mean College for me was 50 grand a
year
I wanted to know when your kids go to
school it's gonna be a hundred grand a
year yeah so like you'll need that lids
I don't know how do you become a
comedian but the subtle of us you know I
mean one thing about me is I got a job
three months into comedy that paid me
200 hours a month doing comedy yeah
which now a lot of people have know I
got 25 bucks a night yeah that's when I
first started yeah so it's like now if I
did one show a week that's what I got
paid for you don't leave from 1991 and I
got no reason to [ __ ]
to 2001 it was basically aunt amount
yeah like we were talking about taxes I
didn't pay taxes from 91 to 2003 when I
went to the IRS they said listen it's we
only go back seven years we only go back
seven years and I laughed and I said I
understand that we just gotta get into
the conversation like I'm aesthetic I
mean I started 91 yeah if I didn't make
a dime like I was blue making I could
have collected food stamps I was like
eight grand a year when I lived in
Seattle I lost money when I did the math
there we are like eighty six hundred
hours that one year and 95 I played but
you know you you look at the years that
you starved for and then life starts
becoming life but then life throws a
curveball at you and gets you a hot-ass
girlfriend and you're living yellow and
you doing stores how many spots at the
store lets you know Judd Apatow calls
you you do two episodes of crash and now
you're selling tickets let me ask you
something and let me ask the people at
home you know you have this family but
at the same time you have this job
that's Thursday through Saturday
you're gonna start small you're not
gonna start at $25 a night and also the
more you go out the more you build an
audience and the more money you make
it's a no-brainer but it's just like
anything else in life Burt not everybody
is the same my first love of this comedy
game was Richard Pryor my second love
was Andrew Dice Clay and then Bill Hicks
and then Kennison but then there was a
guy by the name of Joe Rogan and I
really learned a lot from him and he was
the LA he's the luckiest man in the
world because he creates his own
opportunities he got a news radio and
whose radio ended when the guy got shot
basically then he had like a year off he
already had that notoriety
I still remember he told me once what
they were paying him on the road when he
was on Newsradio there was nothing
really
and then one time they offered him
Caroline's like three days before and he
got a first-class ticket that was our
girls more than what they were paying
them he told me the story like
they weren't paying dick on the road
really yeah the road the vote after news
radio then when fear factor came he got
busy but all this should happen he was
like he was burning the candle at both
ends but I noticed that fear factor was
paying him which gave him a big
advantage over a lot of the comics that
they don't necessarily need to go out
yeah when you buy a three million dollar
house because you're making twenty grand
for two years and also in your show gets
canceled and your crowds gonna have
guess what you're gonna [ __ ] order
collect yeah that means you got to go
out 50 weeks a year to keep the [ __ ]
lights on and you put just be a kid in
Campbell Hall that's another 34 which is
starting to crack me up I couldn't wait
to have you on the podcast to talk about
like the school that your daughter goes
to or bolted them on the one minds on my
daughter supposedly hate and went looked
it up it's a high rated [ __ ] school
in the valley when number one school the
valley but you'll talk to people and
when you ask them where your kids gonna
go they'll take it are they gonna go to
a private school and then when you tell
them you're gonna go to that school they
roll their [ __ ] Isaiah
I've had this ten times the last two
weeks I even had a kid that was selling
lemonade on the corner I went with my
daughter I see this poor kid with a
mother 90 degrees
someone [ __ ] lemonade I run home I
see ya go come on girls let's take a
walk but yeah you know study or say he's
a nice [ __ ] by the way like a little
walk yeah walk you get to the corner the
girls fiery don't right away she starts
towards your mercy you know you're
falling fine just throw a baby a nurse
he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] give me some
lemonade look dad can I hug her a little
effect girl one of the dollar for the
[ __ ] glasses his lemonade so the
little girl has mercy are you in school
yet and mercy was yeah you know I go
nowhere and yes he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] going on the girls tortured her
yeah she was like out of this school and
then my wife asked the mom
what don't you live close to she was
here and down the block she was why
wouldn't you go to this grammar school
and little girl goes yak like I thought
of this 11 mean my daughter and my
[ __ ] wife with it the little girl and
the mother finally goes don't say that
but when she hear that from yeah she
heard it from you you stinky [ __ ] so as
we're walking back that's why she's my
blood and wet daughter that's why I I go
on the road and do this [ __ ] I don't
want to do yeah she looked at me she of
daddy she was mean and I didn't liked
her dilemma they in any way she just
ruin up that's why if I can stay at home
two weeks of [ __ ] that's when you
going at her pony just look at me right
now so what's it name was here three
weeks ago who this guy goes out on the
road every week at least six P I'm
embarrassed who wronged women better but
at the same time he has no children he's
gone he's have somebody's an older I
need some works for him and I think he
just he just got the war he just kind of
worried or what so if I was him I'd look
on the road I live on when you have
nobody at home listen the only times in
the Friday I'm sitting on my couch and I
go yeah my wife just informed me that
she's going to a [ __ ] woman's party
with the kid tomorrow around the corner
and Sunday they got Church how they're
gonna [ __ ] anyway I got a spot here
what the [ __ ] i stay hopeful yeah if my
wife's on her period i don't i
definitely on the road yeah yeah you
always did I said keep me in town for
the girl's birthdays Halloween Halloween
Mother's Day Thanksgiving Christmas I
gotta work New Year's Eve and then every
night every time you have appeared your
period I went on the road and now my
daughter's cycle Georgia I shouldn't say
that out loud but I guess Georgia is a
woman now I don't want to hit a [ __ ] and
her cycle is the same as LeAnn cycle so
cuz I guess that's what happens so they
all their cycles team up so now I'm
gonna add my out when they're both of
them or just both [ __ ] rock
I used to thinking ideas to get coked up
with this girl and she let me eat a
little monkey
why call father Teddy's a [ __ ] like that
whenever I was in the mood for him but
he was so tremendous he a beating at a
table now
yeah and then she played the car like
why should she like he's a [ __ ] for an
hour yet everybody kept snorting coke
and yeah whatever yeah I think you know
you leave a little monkey [ __ ]
I knew her cycle so in those nights when
she called me drunk don't worry yeah
[ __ ] you I can't you know her cycle yeah
if I can't eat your monkey I'm not
wasting the gram want you to think that
you beat one of information in your head
I just love like you chose just knew
from the 22nd to the 27th she believed
22nd to the 27th she's bleeding there's
no reason to go over there not even to
say hello
I had a chick see when she was on her
period once that's discussed she didn't
tell me we were too young we were like
17 and I guess yet appear to be [ __ ] you
know it's like now my wife would just be
like am on my period you can't do that
but I guess it's 17 that's something you
just go I won't say that to anybody I'll
just hope I hope it's not that bad
I was cooked up one night in Miami and I
hooked up with this girl and that she
told me from the beginning so I knew I
was a dead man oh well after a [ __ ]
few grams of coke I said take that
little bat out then show it to me she
goes I have since I had my period I
didn't really shave it she took off her
panties it looked like [ __ ] Julius
Erving it had so much hair I cut through
that [ __ ] thing I took that tampon I
pushed it to the side that little fuse
yeah and I just liked that clip for
about ten minutes until my came in my
pants and I just went to sleep that's
the only time I ever messed around with
a girl at that time in a month so what
did you do close your eyes you Patti
passed out I was on [ __ ] two eight
balls oh you could stab me with 22
needles it wouldn't matter at that time
I was like Whitney used at the time I
had that numb
that's what Whitney dollars she was so
numb shoe in the bathtub and she didn't
feel the temperature of the water
what that's a true story watch [ __ ] I
want top see people she didn't die from
she died from cocaine but in a different
way
was it too hot the water was hot she
boiled herself something we had happened
to her
oh the 4:10 and she slipped and hit her
head something weird the there's a
there's a thing that happens when you
get into a really hot bathtub but Rises
your blood pressure I read a book about
this when I was a kid about it they if
they I don't know [ __ ] I forget how it
goes but they were making baths they
were giving these people this medication
and raise her blood pressure and then
giving them and put him in a susan got a
hot bath they just died because I don't
know I by I don't know it's the same
reason they see you see on hot tubs
people with heart problems shouldn't get
into this hot tub if you've been
drinking no get in the hot tub because
your blood pressure is up I can't go in
the hot tubs because I always get
started I don't know I have bad luck
with hot tubs skies yeah well first off
who goes into a hot tub it's mm [ __ ] of
a hot tub you got a phone and what do I
listen to Jimmy Buffett records aquiline
it I would love like a [ __ ] monkey
anything gonna steam ass it's you know I
want to get one of those outdoor saunas
yeah it's little circle wood things yeah
I would love one of them with all the
[ __ ] diseases and all the [ __ ] that
is crazy when you think about all the
[ __ ] diseases of better in a hotel
pool and then people just getting a hot
tub that's two of just you know there's
come in there you know every kid pisses
and they don't really takes a shower you
got a song for Sun listen for some
Americans a pool jump is a shower some
people think my jumping in the pool they
get out and clean they don't swipe their
ass yeah they don't scrub the nuts the
same way dead skin develops around your
face you gotta get off with a loofah
yeah well they they develops around your
skin when you get welcomed you want to
sit for the pound life when you become
all those fat [ __ ] that you stopped
bathing my daughters and I are obsessed
with my 600 pound law is that the best
show on television
I watched four episodes the two brothers
they hated each other those two more oh
and the one brother that went the one
kid that was on pills that define it the
kids finally said to him you know if you
the next time you fake pain and go to an
emergency room and get a prescription
they gonna charge you with a felony
because you've already exceeded
the amount of lifetime prescription the
person could get in Texas really you
know when you're a fat [ __ ] I think the
pet show does something together you
have to watch and go I don't want to be
that person but those people will that
happens too it's a toss-up I sit there
and watch it and I want listen to their
words and I want their environment and I
think what happens like the fat dude was
on pills you know what makes a person go
you know what I lost my job and part of
it could be the beginnings of depression
but now the depression is worn off and
there you are 800 [ __ ] pounds later
yeah it was a weird thing about the show
it's like there's a lot of people who
wind on it like who like pretend like
they're trying to lose weight there was
a couple like women on the first because
I haven't had cable for a couple years
so the for the first few seasons there
were some women who just like would just
lie and they had cameras in their faces
nobody no showing what they nobody is
going to oh yeah everyone lies about
what I mean it's no it's uh it's a
sickness absolutely a one kid that was
eaten somebody pizza pies to kid up in
New Hampshire the brothers that was the
one kid oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he would
call his father from Houston to order
Domino's for him in Houston that was in
New Hampshire yeah whose or was he not
he made pizzas a day it's you know I'm I
don't I deal with uh I think my real
addiction and life is food meaning like
like tonight when I go home it's gonna
be really it's it's a real battle for me
to just go lay in the bed and go to
sleep and I want to eat something when I
get home like I've been there where you
just go [ __ ] it and then you just start
eating and you just can't stop me like
I'm already uh you know and I but I'm
and I've been the biggest I was 265 and
when I was at 265 it party is just like
I can't turn this boat around we're
sailing so fast in this direction
I don't know how to turn this boat
around and then finally when you start
getting momentum you're like oh there we
go it's like it's like I don't know man
I empathize with those people I
empathize with those people because I go
I feel like I'm I've been there I've
been there you know it was on my way I
would have been absolutely you were huge
yeah and I'm I've gained like 1520
pounds back I was I was 315 I got down
to 227 I'm to 45 to 47 along this yard
for a second the [ __ ] when we all
jump in the lake I forget you were
bigger than this watch look I forget you
were big like whenever this is on like
you scroll down and there's a scene that
it says you're long a shark Comedy
Central
yeah if it's at like the hour mark I'll
put on just to watch that scene and it
makes me feel like the 600-pound man I
forget I forget you were big and I
forgets the girl was big you gotta watch
this ain't like Sakura still looks fat
to me when I see doll hey he looks
tremendous
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] he looks really
nice he looks really good we were hit
and Rogen or like birth gained all the
way back dude I'm still to 22 to 17 that
I got back up to do 22 the other day but
uh but yeah I'm still 220 I'm that so I
floated 220 up and down and so uh but
I'd like to get I don't know if I want
to get like I don't know if I want to do
my next special at 205 where I look good
like what are you reading right now
right now 220 probably 220 220 - yeah
flooded practice field
if you want were you were you out right
now today probably three yeah really you
don't look like you look like you're 300
pounds
pull all the way to the end keep going
keep going
you know you come clink it there you
guys are gonna see something that's
really [ __ ] absurd this every time I
see this I go oh my god oh [ __ ] today I
go to the other one hey when you when it
was Chris Rock fun to work with
um yeah everybody that holy was did he
hang out or was he go to that one once
and um those guys came and went
that's Chris Rock why can't we come and
shoot three scenes and then leave for a
week you can't blame someone like that
he's got kids he's gay marriage together
but I do
if I was that guy I'd be hanging out a
lot Oh Chris Rock yeah I'd be I'd be on
set [ __ ] around and my favorite
things are being on set well he came
with his family you know we shot long
days and was that little bird yeah some
of the guys hung out and some of them
did you know look at that
don't you look at that just look at that
COP of the hell with other scene of that
yeah yeah how much were you weigh in
there at that point I was click to see
the third one they have another one to
see that look at that look at the my
stomach thank you I just saw your face
you tell your face don't even look like
you know it was keep going keep going
[Music]
so we get a little bit more have you
ever seen the rain scene go up go go go
go right there right there
how big were you at that point right
there
I was 380 so you weren't even at your
highest no I walked on that set maybe
360 as soon as I hit New Mexico I
probably gained 15 [ __ ] pounds right
off the bat when I got home from the New
Mexico I went to the doctor because they
kept left busting my balls about blood
pressure what was your blood pressure at
the time look at that and now is that I
think you know all the scale goes all
the way to 350 yeah he kept pushing it
and he finally said to me it ends at 350
but when it's here you're probably at
390 right now Wow
so that was like what's this now
you're ready if they keep this [ __ ]
CNN who's that guy looking at oh my god
but go back and just freeze it on that
one pot spot can you yeah that doesn't
even look like you Joey
now what you don't see is my hands are
up yeah that's as high as my hands could
probably go then that's number one
number two that my stomach was as
extended as my chest at the time yeah
like I had so much fat over here like
that had developed right here really
like when I felt this bone I went to the
doctor immediately I'm like I can't sit
he goes no you don't touch your [ __ ]
like he goes what do you mean he never
felt that I haven't felt this in years
yeah that's because all that fat I have
built out a bunch of fat under my ribs
my tits and my [ __ ] stomach will one
dude my chest and my stomach will
one-eyed you know mine there's pictures
of me if you go online you can find them
there's pictures of me just type in fat
Burt and man when I was 265 and then and
that's not but it's not it's not far off
man that I I was I didn't even know I
was fat I really did I thought was like
nah man I got a big I got a barrel chest
I wasn't weighing myself that's the key
that's the key
yeah I'm the way you saw if you weigh
yourself every day then you're held
account and you find out you really find
out [ __ ] what am I drink last night
oh I ate this I hate that yeah no yeah
no yeah yeah yeah I'll show you that's
nothing there's nothing that's nothing
typing fat Burt Preston and Steve keep
scroll down so I'll show you down scroll
down scroll down you'll see it me and a
speedo in a jean shorts pedo teeth all
right there to the right yeah look at
that
won't we they're 265 drinking fireball
and drink and and Jack at 6:00 in the
morning oppressing us Steve yeah but you
know it was mi Salaam was there and it
was a fun I had a good time I can't lie
to you now when you go to those radio
shows me yeah you get hammered in the
morning oh I'm sleep it off yeah I don't
get so I don't get like you know it's
like me the four or five stars right you
get a little buzz but I get buzzed and
then and then I go to bed and I wake up
and I get on the treadmill I'll walk or
I'll just go right through the club wake
up right before the show go to the club
but it's not getting like like if my
wife did it she wouldn't be able to
function but if I can do it very easily
I will say that I am healthier like I
definitely feel better in the weekend
when that doesn't happen like when you
go in and do radio and there's no booze
and they're like no not like like I'm
talking won't forget where I was just
that but there was no booze and I was
like okay that's fine I don't mind I
don't mind not drinking but if they're
gonna have a cocktail I have a [ __ ]
cocktail you know so it's the same way
of like someone build a joint you're not
gonna say no you gotta get you know but
there's there's radio shows some of them
get out of control something like those
concept to work towards I do those are
insane man I've been on stage where I've
been blacked out and not been able to
function and then you go home I need to
sleep to be back that you won't know
what happened so I was in Tampa and I do
a contact works right go to Cal hate
show Mike Alta I do his show and we
start drinking on air and and ice and I
start drinking uh Manhattan's and I and
I'm not even my god at what time there's
like seven in the morning Oh shows at
10:00 or shows it at noon but we had
done at 10:00 and we drink all morning
and I and I don't feel it I'm really not
feeling it and then I get to the club
I'm a little buzzed but it's sold out if
they've already drank the club out of
beer the fans drank everyone out of beer
there's no beer left all their heart
making is mixed drinks so that means
just everyone's already [ __ ] hammered
now they're getting it more hammered
because they can't get any but mixed
drinks so I get off stage and they start
sending fireballs like crazy like like
but but maybe I maybe I did I don't even
know how many I did all I know is I
blacked out I did a mean greet don't
remember any of the meet-and-greet um
there are pictures of me with my eyes
just like this like huh my dad picks me
up and my parents had built a new house
that I'd never been to so I I remember
my old house my dad picks me up takes me
to my new house his new house to these
living in with my mom I pass out in the
guest room I wake up my dad's not there
and I have no [ __ ] idea where I am
but I get up I'm like okay I don't know
it state I'm in
I don't know like I'm trying to you know
you wake up some mornings you're like
where the [ __ ] am i I'm like my in Tampa
I'm like [ __ ] I'm literally panicking
looking around this house I don't
recognize anything I've never been to
this house and then my dad walks and I
go what are you doing here and he's like
oh boy buddy you were here and a rough
mode when I picked you up I was like I
didn't know who the [ __ ] house I was
at but yeah those those concept
workshops get out of control how many
hours do yet have to sleep to wake up
and be tip-top Magoo for Oh God
oh my god for like see like when you
come in here and you watch your seat and
edibles
but that blows me away and you get blown
away I got to but I'm blown away that
does nothing like what you
professionally do and you know how to
tell you something I grew up in a bar
yeah I grew up around people who drink
you know I know who's faking the funk
yeah to be cool and I knows really Robin
yeah a lot of comedians that fake the
funk to be cool yeah that's great I'll
play a little [ __ ] buddies of The
Improv that impressed them but I don't
[ __ ] rule really and you're one
of those guys and I've always admired
that number one I'm a child of the 70s
what did you see on TV in the 70s when I
was on Rogen's theatre which I showed
the beginning of the original along his
yard everybody in the south it was great
everything else in the 70s everybody
every TV show at one point of a knock on
the door opened up coming and Burt would
get up and there wasn't like would you
like a drink or what do you I was
drinking you turned around and there was
a glass thing that was brown it could be
anything while perky yeah bourbon could
be anything and they poured two when
they gave you one of the gentlemen drank
it the one is this is jin-woo I'm gonna
antibiotics right now no nobody will
antibiotics and if you did do an
elephant honey just give me the [ __ ]
whisk in drinking you know I tried that
Burt I desperately tried to fit in as a
drinker early on and it was like I would
puke I would pass out mom the same way
that you are with booze were weed cuz I
don't mind smoking a little weed like I
can I have a sit only because I'm
running a lot I'd hit are this packs
vaporizer and it just it in my opinion I
don't feel it in my lungs the next day
like I like the packs but I like the one
that you put weed in this is that's this
one no because you said it's kind of
- I got - I don't want to travel with
right and I got this one we got hacked
that's the best thing going oven and
from the meat jogging why's it doesn't
[ __ ] with my lungs that's the best one
going cuz when I when I hit like I did
this sounds so silly but like if I had a
joint with paper I can feel it the next
day when I run listen it's a very early
statement though no it's not I need this
weed for my jogging why the [ __ ] do you
think I smoke out of a bong Bronson was
easy the other day that real good smoke
how you had Action Bronson yeah it
smoked for [ __ ] day his first album
was [ __ ] phenomenal I just listened
to it it's great there's there's this
song you guys don't play music on here
yeah we do whatever the [ __ ] yeah this
is the song that I [ __ ] I've just I
eyes man I'm really impressed with that
kid yeah me I say kid only because I'm
so much older than him but uh Action
Bronson the doctor lecture album is it
uh suede have you heard that I don't
know I don't think so is it this one
exhale the [ __ ] essence I love this
every [ __ ] Ryan he's God I like this
one this is one that first for me I just
[Music]
love that I love the cadence of it I
love dude I love Action Bronson you own
one man and know who he was
oh he's great man that's a great hit
from the Rogan podcast oh yeah you guys
got must got [ __ ] hammered telling me
to bring him on he came on dog he didn't
stop rolling joints he smokes
collectively if you can get cancer from
marijuana he'll be the death it's
hysterical
I could go bong the bottleneck of smoke
lungs all [ __ ] night yeah he smokes
doubt he's a big Avenue I can't do it
that's it I'm done with all that [ __ ]
boy why don't you do dabs because I
don't want to blow towards your [ __ ]
house hey listen
yeah cuz I guess if you got that
blowtorch going and you're doing a DAB
and you pass out listen you light a
[ __ ] house on fire it's a joke it's a
[ __ ] joke they grew up in the [ __ ]
babies young people are having a great
time people going out and going Bert you
a little boy yeah that's gonna grab a
blow-up you guys having a great time and
then one day I just graduated high
school and this dude Steve battle and
this comes up to me he calls me and he
goes hey man that's one good coke I want
to hook up with this dude all right we
get my boy Timmy's listening for this
he's dying
he gets in the car with me and when
Timmy's brother Roger and we're going on
to this hotel and Connolly I
the admin was like well [ __ ] crack
b-boying huh there was no crack at that
time no it was nineteen it was summer of
82 he pulling till his nasty Hotel
answer this is black dude with a pool
this [ __ ] you know I give him the coke I
saw him he gives me the cash
he see tasted he was a tremendous didn't
say it was tremendous this is good stuff
and he goes you guys ever smoked it and
I'm like no and he right there in front
of us it was 2:00 in the afternoon
yeah he cooked it up we you know in
those days you had like the vial that
you said - right there yeah you'd had
one of those was a little thicker you
fill it you fill half of water and you
put a half a gram of coke in there and
two points of baking soda and you'd
shake it up shake it up shake it up
shake it shake it up shake it up shake
them put some heat - and all something
caught would burn out and you get a
little rocket you had to get a [ __ ]
still cactus ship or pay your father's
[ __ ] silk socks and lean it and then
put the rock on top of there and then
you had away five minutes it's the
hardened and then I had to take the rock
cuddle up and we'd sit there and put it
into a pipe West at the process all over
again shake and it was cool for the
afternoon
yeah but we smoked the whole a born ten
[ __ ] minutes and then I went home but
it was interesting to me but already
there was a head shop in my home and
units in New Jersey I forget what it's
called somebody hit me up in two minutes
on Twitter and tell me east west and
they had a [ __ ] starter crack kit
let's start a really free base they
called it number when they can get seen
who's free was not cracked it was
freebase and you went down there and for
50 bucks which was a lot of money I
remember paying fifteen going I could
just get a half gram of coke why am i
doing this at that time I got coke from
a guy named camel breath he smoked Camel
cigarettes all the time without filters
and his cigarette his Mustang orange and
his fingers ARDS and do you know that
till today he still won't friend me on
Facebook
he's still alive oh he's still alive
camel breathy smoking
I don't be had to quit yeah he's about
me if I'm 54 he's got to be 70 something
oh my god yeah breath I thought he was
building a coke no we used to get coke
from him and he used to sell us coconut
vile already but have you got coke from
the camel if you bought an Eightball
it's really giving you instead of giving
you three they're happy just give you
four tubes and call it even
I went over there boy twelve eight balls
one night I collected the thing was
sixty a piece he was given to me for I
would sound for his doing me a favor the
other day maybe two I would have a self
eighty I was still making twenty bucks
so I went over there bought like [ __ ]
ten of those things and I went to my
buddy's house where he opened up that
[ __ ] kid and me having another one of
us just started [ __ ] doing that
kicking it up and I'll never forget
waking up on his cat's the next morning
it was three of us
nobody was sleep on the table and every
single coke bottle but I had was turned
upside down like an order
yeah like bullets and I'm like oh my god
we smoked all that [ __ ] last night at
the end of the day just wasn't worth it
how do you pass out when you do that
much whoever's doing quaaludes that oh
is that what yeah we will [ __ ]
whatever you hung out with my man
see that's my thing that I'd I won't do
is if I feel like if I have a if I have
a heart like I had a real rough week
partying in New York I thought might
have done drugs I'm not certain I was
pretty blacked out one night and I don't
I don't ever black out but I was
definitely blacked out and I saw someone
else do drugs and I he doesn't do drugs
at all at all I saw two people do drugs
they don't do drugs and I went I just
remember giggling at it and then I woke
up and I was like I think I [ __ ] did
drugs last night and I was shaky like
shaky and then I went in I did Jim and
Sam had a big cup of coffee and then me
and Sam went to go see Planet of the
Apes the new one and I went home and I
was like [ __ ] man I can't operate but I
won't take a xanax to chill out just go
to bed because I feel like hey man if
you're gonna dig these graves
you gotta live in them like you know I
mean does that make sense you don't know
no I had mine you got to pay the piper
you can't [ __ ] it I'm punitive about
that like this morning I woke up I did a
podcast with the you know Adam rant and
Brad Williams and we got pretty [ __ ]
let Adam race booked
I didn't race booked two joints just by
himself just by himself I told him you
and Adam you and Adam would get down I
think both home would like he's a big
weed guy but
we stayed up until like midnight I go to
sleep at like 2:00 I wake up at 7:00 I
have a callback for a voiceover and I go
I'm punitive I go nah man you're not
allowed to be that party guy and not
work out so I get on the treadmill and I
run to really hard miles
I walked one intermittently and then ran
to really hard miles and I was like
funky here we go
and then I began to get sweatin I get in
the shower
I keep getting real hot shower so I keep
sweating I get out of Charlotte I keep
stuff keep sweating to get all the
impurities out and then I rolled the
voice over and I felt really good I felt
fantastic girls said how do you how you
doing that said by the best I've been in
a while I love that feeling got the new
car drove the new car oh it was a
[ __ ] great morning and then I went
down to all things comedy shot some
promos came home had dinner I'm here but
I'm feeling so good this morning you
just got to punish yourself don't be
don't go American with it pawn is
yourself
don't say I'm gonna tap out take a xanax
say I'm getting on the treble I'm gonna
do kettlebells or I'm gonna go to
jujitsu I'm gonna do you said it today
um I smoked all that other joint I'm
doing two sessions of images in 112 if
you're not cheap unitive I don't think
you succeed when I was about 14 I
started getting popular you know my
freshman year stuck around and seeing
other people at first I just did my
neighborhood like my hometown is really
big
there's seven gram schools I kept in my
own grammar school but after why you
stretch out into other territories and
you know kids are those the
those are the fun times yeah I don't
know what these kids that had to hold
the brothers and their older brothers
work the [ __ ] yeah
so whenever they had parties had bought
me a pass to go into those parties so
it's probably my freshman year like
April it's not high yet but it's not
cold yet they lived maybe three quarters
of a mile from my house and the bit
about this family well my mother died
they asked me if I'm gonna live with
them and I really didn't know him that
well I thanked them but they had a shed
and the one that was my you we would get
together
five nights a week in the shed no heat
yeah no he New Jersey November you come
always smoke 25 joints but they know he
yeah other nights we spent out there but
it was one of those nights and he called
me up because my brother's having one of
his [ __ ] crazy parties it's only
gonna be me you and Conti better invited
from our age group don't say nothing
they just don't want no younger kids
there yeah you know and I won't expect
them to get abused a little bit that's
what you do when you're a sophomore and
you're in a room with seniors yeah
especially after they won the state
championship of football they're all
[ __ ] yoked and you know so I think
that I'm in a matter of fact that wasn't
what it was they were very nice to me
but these guys wanted druggies they were
[ __ ] crazy white boosters so what they
did was they would do things none of
nobody else did at parties again that's
what I loved about that like this
particular party they just went shopping
and bought every [ __ ] flavor of booze
they can and they took a garbage can and
they put a baggie in it and they just
filled it up with [ __ ] booze ice
cubes and fruit they made a hunch plant
it tasted like garbage but they also
went and killed the hundred bees and
threw him in the punch huh to flavor the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah everything with
these guys was pure savagery one time
they had a Christmas party and I walked
in and there was a table and they were
breaking glass on the table that we know
[ __ ] nice there were nuts and that's
why I like oh they went hunting for bees
and sprinkles and cut the heads off or
cut this things off and threw them all
on this one so you didn't know what the
[ __ ] you were drinking in there they
threw masks in there you know but you
didn't know do you get it I'm [ __ ] 14
you know like I said I'm a pot smoker at
that time I did a little mescaline got
angel dust maybe once at all I'm not a
professional they kill them then they
cut their [ __ ] stingers off oh and
they threw him into this punch and me
stinky we'll all go to this party and I
don't know nothing about nothing they're
pouring it was at the ladle into your
ass and there's one guy that was me
there's one guy that would come up to
you and just punch in the chest every
time by Bauman's he said that [ __ ]
classes that Dianna I mean he would just
cave your chest do you know that in this
story I see a punched up version of your
album cover you ever seen you know
Joey's album cover of like I do all I
see is like a little bit bigger version
of that kid so he's that kid that is my
favorite picture you Joey oh that kid
that's that if you pull it up real quick
so I can see it damage down
no no documentary splack those hams what
did your mom say splatters well you I'm
telling I'm on the guy mow down the
hormones that when there's a part of you
that I don't think everyone knows about
me but before I even met you I was on
the road doing Travel Channel and I
become a van der Rohe his podcast and I
and I knew Tommy I knew Ari a little bit
and I kind of knew red band and I didn't
know you at all but you guys were my
favorite ones to listen to and so I
would put you guys on in the bed next to
me in the bed on my iPad and I just let
it play cuz I had anxiety on the road so
it's do a crazy [ __ ] and I was like
almost like my friends were in the other
room and I'm home although even in this
sounds so crazy but not to anyway
listening because you know what you're
saying you know what I'm saying but like
even though I wasn't even didn't even
know you I still felt like my friends
were in the other room I didn't even
know Joe at the time but I still felt
like my friends are in the other room I
love that [ __ ] picture that is where
like where it where I get my balls from
that is my favorite that is such a great
[ __ ] picture I tell you something
guys let me tell you the [ __ ] story
about in this picture that is my mom my
mom came from dead guys it was nine kids
and two parents her bedroom and my uncle
told me that they used to [ __ ] look
at the bracelet the bracelet in those
days was two of these it was two of
these really hot so you see it's a
double bracelet but let me tell you the
story behind this guys just to show you
I think I'm Rogan one time I said
immigrant mentality and people always
make fun of me and [ __ ] my mom grew up
in this thing and what my mom told me
one time is that since they were so poor
they didn't celebrate birthdays and it
always bothered my mother but the mother
like something like my grandmother yeah
believed in it but my grandfather didn't
because they were so poorly than one
that they couldn't give him a gift so he
wouldn't celebrate their birthday so my
mother always swore that if she ever had
a family
on that kids or daughter's birthday she
would lose her [ __ ] mind
my mom would work hard all [ __ ] year
to wait for this my mom's big season was
from December 17th to January 7th if I
brought you to the ball I'm the seventh
17th of January 7th of you were 13 or 12
yeah and you came in and acted cute from
my mom my mom would give me 50 bucks and
saying the events from how you liked my
mom what but that's at the point yes the
point is every year she would hire the
photographer from the New York City
newspaper the Spanish newspaper daddy
Penza and this guy would come to my
mother's bar from the age of three that
I came from Cuba and every February 19th
that whole week my mom would take those
suits a tailor made really she would
tale and make those two of them I'd have
a mourning party and a night party ready
this is what Bert Kreischer would fell
right into my family the morning party
was children children under 12 children
on the 18th they came there was ham
there was mojito split alumni sandwiches
am deviled ham Cuban style oh oh white
bread have you ever had that's what else
I got to show you Lee when I show you
this you might be saying I was having on
the Boston to visit my father but me and
Paul I gotta go to Miami now I can't
take it no more [ __ ] listen I leave
those are like [ __ ] 10 cents apiece
it's on Wonder Bread Lee it's a deviled
ham Cuban style
I'm Wonder Bread they cut the edges off
Lee once you bite into it you're done so
I'm not getting anything until I get a
proper honor that thing so you see that
that's ham there's bow Carlitos so
here's what gets interesting I said a
happy birthday
this is this motherboard this is this is
the daytime party my mother's big
highlight was in the daytime party there
was a pinata and when you pulled the
string it was for kids yeah and there
would be like candies and stuff but
there would also be like $20 bills for
the kids right and there was an adult
pinata that's when all the kids went
home and the parents came I'd come out
with a different suit the parents of my
mother was a spy with less of I have no
idea my mother was a speck speck you
know the speck of speck is she took it
to the that I had that bracelet by the
time I was 2 like I had a man's bracelet
on when I was due for the adult party
she would put a little little balls of
cocaine them for the adults and put them
in the pinata
hello hotline 30 they pull the string
all these adults would be on the floor
looking for okay and [ __ ]
oh I'll see what taping they'll go in
there get in there and mix it up with us
and pick up all the little falls that
you see for mommy and I knew what was in
those coils I knew what was in those
walls I may believe why they're always
in those balls I haven't heard the term
[ __ ] in so long yeah it's a nice girl
like that one day that was a grown up in
high school that was and I and I say
this like I'm sure that there's no one
PC listen to this podcast
they're like growing up that's what we
call like that was it was just like a
term of endearment
well when the [ __ ] came out you were
you're from where Tampa yes Oh [ __ ] all
wrong cuteness Christ we got to deal
with these [ __ ] on the other side of
town name of the town I remember I
remember they going would like I
remember going up to a lunch table and
go uh-huh
Hey he speaks speaks was like it was a
great nickname I'm sure was offensive to
guys that you know like no very offense
reason very a fantasy you know it stands
for yes lots of what just for Spanish
people no you did there's [ __ ] as a
acronym okay no I think I heard a
banished people in our country oh my god
his people in command [ __ ] Jesus to the
parlor documentary with carmine Bowser
handle says I love that picture this is
this a mourning party or a nine part
that was the morning party see the kids
in the back you remember that picture at
all yeah so listen my mom would take him
and put him in albums she'd take him so
when I was the last party she had for me
was when I was 14 so she had basically
11 hours from this country yeah from
those parties they were wrapped they
were thick and then went through the
beginning me walking into the bar on the
ice February 19th so all the way I could
look at I could I could literally I can
I can i man you know cigar now we're
talking about you the other day behind
you back in the best possible way
you were so funny on Rogan and you
weren't you weren't trying it all
that there's a thing about your
personality that that is it's almost
like the the top of the mountain when it
comes to like guys like me as a girl who
found our voices on podcasting but like
you are so in the moment you could tell
a story better for the first time then I
could tell a story better working on it
for four years does that make sense and
I need to say that about you like you
telling the story for the first time it
has such a genuine energy and we were
like God man like thank God a medium
like this came up I'll say this for me
thank God a medium like this came along
for me me cuz but me be you me and you
and me like miss Pat like we would have
been dead without this medium right now
[ __ ] I said I said to my agent maybe or
someone other we were talking about um
about social me and they're like you've
really blown up on podcasting and I said
yeah but I think podcasting from and I
use menu interchangeably only because
because I think it's done really good
things for our careers but I go I know
10 people it's done great things like
yeah I can get 10 people who are doing
tremendously different who started
podcasting
took him a while to get it going yeah
and once you pick up the momentum and
it's just being honest being consistent
if phonies get faded out of podcasting
very very quickly and oh yeah
you'll see them they were in the first
living the first run of Rogen when Rogen
was like let's have this guy on and then
he's just like I'll never have that guy
on again stop talking to a guy doesn't
know who he is like I'm not look now I'm
starting get buzzed but like I'm not I'm
not talking [ __ ] but I'm just saying
like you'll see the guys that don't do
podcasts their acts are a little bit
like inflated it's not really who there
are there are they're not all true you
know but the guys the podcast is just
people who would have had a hard time
being funny in Hollywood but can be very
genuine in those moments and I'm saying
to someone I'm saying you know Twitter
blew up there was a guy I forget his
name I'm Rob Delaney right it was a guy
that blew up on Twitter it was because
Rob Delaney is a great writer he's a
really smart guy he's a really he's got
his [ __ ] together
and in 160 characters he can
the best joke you're gonna see in a
while Jenny hi-5 Johnson
Kelly Oxford all these people were
really smart really great it like
conciseness of words and then podcasting
showed up and guys like me and you were
like I mean us to this day the hardest
I've ever laughed on a podcast ever was
when you were me you Steve Rannazzisi
Rogen we're all sitting at that table
and in the Icehouse chronicles and he's
like dog you ever break into houses at
chicks house on a credit neither [ __ ]
and you know that doesn't work on
twitter but the way you did it then all
of a sudden you go oh this is my new
best friend this is the person I want to
be around a lot when you said blue
cheese with over ranch or go [ __ ] your
mother like though those things they
don't fit on that doesn't make sense on
Twitter where you can take things out of
context but in a world where you like to
be in context like I like being in
context and that's where it's like what
I said spit earlier if you take that out
of context I was having a really
horrible person but but I'm not a bad
person I'm telling you a story about my
life about interacting with all Cuban
kids growing up and the word [ __ ] being
interchangeable for buddy or that guy or
you know so I'm showing you through
those picks off the table there were
your buddies sticks taught me how to bug
until to tell a story
[ __ ] you sit with a group you said with
a kid a table of Cuban kids and you and
your the NAM not saying like I'm the
white kid I was underprivileged if it
was a private school but like you sit
down with a table Cuban kids all their
dads have big personalities all them
have big personalities there wasn't like
I don't remember one quiet Cuban kid
growing up ty Rodriguez I mean that
[ __ ] made me laugh harder than
anyone's ever made me laugh when we were
in mr. Merkin Dante's religion class ty
Rodriguez sat behind me and mr. Merkin
Dante said when Jesus was at the top of
the cross he called Peter to his feet he
said something to Peter do you know what
he said to Peter
mr. cruncher What did he say to Peter
like trying to stomp me I don't know but
he forgot said to Peter and Ty Rodriguez
leaned up behind me in my ear he goes he
said I can see your house from here
and I [ __ ] died laughing but my
personality was developed around guys
like that like that's that's you know
I'm gonna tell you something and I'm
gonna be as long as I can with you they
listen there's a lot of mediums where
people Excel and they excel for
different reasons and I believe in one
thing I believe in hard work
yeah I believe in dedication and I
believe in commitment but I also believe
in for all the time you know they've
been pushing McGregor all week all week
if you watch 2:18 FX 1 FX 618 then
whatever spy whatever they been showing
me with the number 4 they have all these
different UFC shows but it's all wrapped
up around McGregor which I can
understand like I tell you what moving
them and playing all week since this
thing happened Charlotte fell a time to
kill with Sandra Bullock and some of
that work has had it on 24 hours since
that day yeah but they showed the first
McGregor a Diaz fight okay and I'll
never forget I'm no [ __ ] genius
I was backstage with Joe I heard Joe
talking with [ __ ] Cameron hands and a
mother bunch of people and I'm sitting
there go man
the hardest thing I've ever done in my
life
hardest thing I've ever ever done in my
life
it's [ __ ] jujitsu training yeah and I
have done a lot of things I worked on
roofs I was a [ __ ] we calls people
carry bricks whatever the [ __ ] they
thought carries bricklayers house area i
shit's hard okay I started when I was 50
and I thought about doing it for 15
years and made a black belt
but I thought about what he had said it
one of the things that he even like
jujitsu late the only reason why he
would go is because you know the guys
would buy him with a burrito yeah yeah
and another thing so I'm starting to
think I'm gonna wait at six seven hours
a day of rolling but 1215 years you know
when I'd be the one to be able yeah you
have any [ __ ] idea what should I grab
your wrist it be tonight night they
would tell you if Joey Diaz grabs your
wrist just tap yeah as I pull you down
and choke you to [ __ ] out and that's
what fun experience that's the only
reason I bet the amount of money I did
on ideas in the first fight yeah because
I believe in experience when this
podcasting game came in I was up to
corner peeing in a bottle at Ford
dealership yeah I went in there to paint
a powerful looking for a job I was done
I was done oh you were the [ __ ] dying
you were the first guy that was good at
it I was dying to know we talked about
this the other night Monday night we
spoke about Mia Felicia I started a
podcast and we did we were lost we were
like in that listen you for leasing you
were lost when you started this but
nobody you own Rogan what was what was
no no no no listen when I started with
Felicia we were lost we were two people
talking every Tuesday we got a couple
downloads but like I told really a day
there were these things that covered our
faces these circles elders yeah can't
spit so I couldn't really see her and
she couldn't really see me and one night
she said something we have to look at
she said some and I thought I got you
know one night I was in the city I mean
my buddies would like to get blown or in
a ball and right by 42nd Street in the
mid eighties it was a pretzel thing if
you wanted to be took the Lincoln Tunnel
back to Jersey I could stop and get a
pretzel there but if you didn't make
that left and you went straight and made
it right the whole street was hookers
and the little pimp was a dude a black
dude and they believed he was [ __ ]
and will
well you have a two machine and then
there was two other [ __ ] black dudes
in wheelchairs well it would drive down
that block and there'd be [ __ ] 20
black chick the cops weren't on it and
you get in the car and they'd suck your
dick around the world or sex
this is 82 no condoms I remember I read
around the world me and around the world
I thought around the world was sex now
around the world's around the world
every day your [ __ ] they suck your
balls your [ __ ] they blow you it's
the whole thing for like 35 hours little
Jesus it's like teen 82 no come no Conda
leave in the backseat of a car on your
back eating that ass and she and the
last time guys she [ __ ]
she doesn't remember there was no handy
wives then there was no chlorine snaps
they took they took like water from a
hose and wash their [ __ ] and went back
water from a hose like a [ __ ] raid
easily like a workman trying to get what
anyway it really doesn't matter Bert
with television with told him the story
I don't know forget talking about how I
got in the car and I'm command committee
you're absolutely right Bert you were
absolutely right because you're a comic
and you understand I'm looking at this
mic and I'm telling this story like I'm
there we all get in the car and the hook
is saying why are we going and my
buddy's going yeah take him back to
Jersey take him back to Jersey and she's
gonna I can't go to Jersey and when we
shut the [ __ ] up and the next thing you
know she goes in the purse and she takes
her straight razor and she goes to cut
the driver and my friend punches her in
the face I don't know what to do Bert I
just grabbed it by the hammer when I
pull it's a wig so we take the knife
from my hand awesome punches not coming
from everywhere my three buddies are
just throwing laps and Lloyds palooka we
take it to the Lincoln [ __ ] tall we
take that into North Bergen into fabulou
Jersey into a cemetery allegedly wanted
allegedly have a lady to you can't prove
this [ __ ] right we take her into this
[ __ ] cemetery we take her out of the
car with a [ __ ] give us the [ __ ]
money we were gonna rob her the point
right then and there I looked at ref
Alicia it's a leash
is like this burg pressure I busted out
laughter and that's when I knew right
there right there now I did the other
Tuesday yeah okay
the bout just got released on a Thursday
I had a show at who's on Melrose now
fighting for his life doing comedy Sal
Sal's comedy hole was on La Brea South
County hole had just left New York City
he wasn't expand his operations he had
one in New York save the village I was
very hot and then he was expanding his
operations to LA and he had one on the
breath I had booked her own a percentage
deal he calls me up and he goes hey
where are you I'm on the 101 he goes
hurry up got a hundred people him really
I go here we go another guy telling me
to hurry up I get there that's ten
people he goes no you got a hundred
[ __ ] 18 people pay ya $10 to see that
was the beginning dude
I remember when we did my very first
podcast and Lee is gonna help me get all
those back up but you have to I should I
need to tell everyone that just to turn
off download all that's all just
download and only new the new one not
old ones but uh when I did my first
podcast with you told his story about uh
IIIi I took it out my dad my dad called
me he goes buddy with other couple
cocktails Joey said some stuff he may
not want out there and then dad Joey is
not never said like anything that Joey
says he's cool was saying nobody goes
nobody you got to take these things out
I just think they incriminate Joey tiny
but let my dad maybe take it on his
knees you don't want to be associated
with this it's a really mad crimes
and I was like dad I heard that Jo's in
prison then he was like ah he doesn't
want that mentioned that could really
hurt his resume I was like dad
Joey is who he is that's why we love him
and he's like listen it's why we love
him but I just don't know you don't know
who's gonna listen to this you know what
if what if what if NBC list is just no
one I are for Joey for something you
don't want to be the reason Joey didn't
get the job
I was like dad you need to listen to
more Joey and then cut to the next time
you meet him you gave him marijuana my
dad's like release the entire thing
release the Kraken there's things that
Joey would say that he says to me on the
phone that are worse than the Donald
sterling tapes like all y'all wouldn't
ever when that was happening I said we
would just laugh because if I ever
recorded anything like but like they
would even know that for you you just
said everything I think that if we tape
recorded Lee Ruby could release this
album I really think so because there's
times I got off the phone with Lee and
we'll both [ __ ] out I'm funny in
Spanish I'm funny in English I'm funny
when I tell a story but when I'm on a
roll it's when I'm on a phone call with
somebody and we start talking about [ __ ]
we go over Lee and I go but I started I
started like for mine when I was doing
that long long time ago over that couple
years ago I was doing a vlog and if you
called I would throw the camera on and
your ramp that first that five minute
rant you'd give someone when you saw him
oh yes I'm Tarzan like and I would
always put them in there and go I know
you're cool with that like I'd like you
and Segura if you guys call me and I and
I'm on a radio show or whatever I go
it's there so fun you guys are so funny
in the moment regardless of whether or
not you're being recorded or not I'm
gonna I'm gonna announce this right now
I'm quitting comedy at the end of 2018
I'm quitting the podcasting and I'm
gonna open up a service I still have to
figure out a price
why call you five days a week between
5:00 a.m. and 8:00 a.m. oh my god I pick
for this now you're gonna get a three no
no no no no I'm not even giving me
giving you three days you're gonna get
nothing you have to pay for everything
in my world you guys have proved to you
what I could do in the morning listen to
me you have problems if you have
physical problems or emotional problems
or drug problems or you're a little lazy
I'm your last [ __ ] pilot defense
I like this Joey okay it's gonna be a
90-day program and I'm gonna call you up
five days a week and guess what if you
don't answer I'm gonna get the paperwork
signed then I send a cop to your [ __ ]
house until you do answer no I like this
no no I really went to an attorney if it
doesn't if they don't answer and they
either get charged double these people
who think that a motivational can't
calendar is gonna help you because you
guys don't understand what it is to be
down you guys don't understand what it
is to wake up in a rocket ship with a
jacket on like under a rocket ship like
an apart
oh you woke up with a rocket ship
where's Joey an astronaut and you have
no money you have a coke addiction you
know you have to dress I would go to my
buddy's dress break them to his back
window
take a shower take a sweatshirt do
laundry eat some breakfast and then my
day would begin but what kept me going
was the things they used to say to
myself when I was laying there yeah
which is the thing as I said to myself
when I was here in LA in the beginning
it's lying the morning you could sit in
this apartment and do what every other
comic does make-believe he's writing and
[ __ ] about how nothing's working for
that's the percentage oh yeah or you
could get yourself up you fat sack of
[ __ ]
I mean what are you gonna do you follow
Allah what are you gonna do with your
felonious [ __ ] life with yeah well
yeah you're gonna impress me with your
felonious what listen you got parents
you got people that love you and people
care for you and you don't want to get
up because your [ __ ] hurts so
[ __ ] little shaky I wish it with the
depression this [ __ ] ends now his uncle
Joey telling you to get the [ __ ] up
and then you got to do something when
you get to the [ __ ] destination you
have to go to when you get to that gym I
want you to call me from there leave a
[ __ ] message it better come up on my
[ __ ] phone that it's coming from you
I'm not even gonna answer the phone I
just want to make sure you get the way
you don't you know I love you I'm sorry
I had to talk to you this way have a
phenomenal day you bad [ __ ] if I
don't love you Jesus doesn't just hang
up on me why can't you you should you
should have said that's the sort of
version of that right now a business no
no I gotta figure I gotta get the
attorneys I already wrote it out Liam
love that I'll leave I get high and talk
about business plans I said you know
what I'm gonna narrow it down please
come to me with calendars somebody else
came to me with t-shirts that the thing
is to call in the morning telling you
that you're a [ __ ] sack of [ __ ] that
the world owes you nothing you're not
special
your mother and father lied to you just
like they lied to me and one day we all
come to the conclusion that nobody's
gonna give you dick you miserable [ __ ]
get up go shampoo make some coffee I
want you to wash your hair I want you to
comb it I want you to put on a white
[ __ ] shirt I want you filled with
wooly there was a black shirt that's
ready we'll go in the [ __ ] wash it
yeah I hate the white shirt on I in it
but come on on it I'm not gonna narrow
down nationalities but people do it all
the time and when I share the second you
know there'd be a lot of people there no
it's true because people need you listen
it's the same [ __ ] your dad tells you
only a broken record only was something
bad is there like a nice version for
people who like there's no the middle
world here card to listen to me the
world ain't nicely the world a nice
there's a guy that's coming in to apply
for the same job as you you have no high
school education and you want to take
off the we gonna go see the State Fair
there goes the ZZ Top well there's a
Mexican who just came in and he said who
do you job for 750 an hour and you're
getting ten guess what's gonna happen
when you get back from your ZZ Top
you're gonna get fired this is our [ __ ]
I prevent you from doing absolutely
there's no concerts there's no nothing I
want your bank statements
I want what y'all so the torture that
you've given me over the years you're
gonna despair no reason to go on
vacation looking for your life turn
around Lee George it's great I'm just
lonely looking your [ __ ] visa bill
and tell me if you got time to take your
[ __ ] wife on vacation attend just ask
me one more time dad you who the [ __ ]
you live on vacation for times or one
year you barely made 42,000 last year
who the [ __ ] are you Donald eel all
right this is my dad my dad you sound
like my dad right now remember on my
birthday my 26th birthday I wasn't doing
stand-up and I was uh I was I was just
[ __ ] partying in New York and he
called me in the morning and I said I
answered the funks I thought he's gonna
wish me happy birthday and go back to
bed so I was hungover
and I was like hello and he's like
you're a piece of [ __ ] nothing dad he
was like I heard myself in court today
the judge asked how you were doing I was
under oath and I said you're doing great
he was I lied about you because you're
such a piece of [ __ ] I was like you know
it's my birthday right
anything goes you don't deserve a
birthday and I was like I go I remember
he gave me a great speech that I'm very
grateful I got because it changed the
direction of my life but at the same
time at the very end of the speech I
said he goes you go to that comedy club
and you tell him you'll work for 25
you'll work for free and again 25 bucks
a night because your work for free and
do whatever they want you to do I said
dad but I have a party tonight because
you don't deserve a party he goes you go
to that club if you let this be your
party let work be your party let Ernie
Simon beer party and it was it's it's
such an impatient truth yeah I was a
hipster way before hipsters and
Millennials I believed I was in
privilege I was like I deserve things I
didn't deserve [ __ ] there was a guy that
was willing to do it before me and then
that guy would get it and I just and I
that that night that conversation on my
26th birthday changed my life there's a
dude Matt Woods I think about every week
not the biggest kind of
let the toughest kind of world just a
guy from Long Island wrote for Roseanne
he was a very decent guy I tell this
story to fuckton I think about him all
the time I look him up on Facebook
because without him
Papa wouldn't be and after like two
years in County one night he came up to
me after an open mic Bert Kreischer
not to this Joe Diaz he went up to crazy
job he hasn't been before
when I was going through a divorce I had
no money then she wouldn't let me see
the kid the anger was spilling on me
they walked me on the way out after I
had just killed open mic three minutes
on the Tuesday for me in those days I go
up there with no material yeah you're by
the way you could still go there is
incumbent I got on stage before I was
leaving he pulled me aside man was a
he's got a writing class that was free
on Tuesday before the open mic so if you
went to his house he'd feed you a bunch
of Thomas girls guys and he would suit
you ask you what you're working on and
he would do this to Comedy Works pay
them yeah it was called the Comedy Works
development plan and when they told his
day I give him props because a lot of
the traumas came from that scamp you
call it Wendy now cooler than I'm going
there for the first time Sunday night
she's tremendous Sunday I'm doing Sunday
Monday and Tuesday she's forgot you
invented that was Wendy Curtis really
when I first started konami her lineup
for the week would be at that time
Jackie Flynn was on [ __ ] fire Jackie
Flynn from Boston Boston was the hottest
comic in the country he had just won the
San Francisco Comedy Competition I'll
never forget the other comic that was
very hot at that time 1994 was Felicia
Michaels I will say this I have to say
this in all it like just to put it out
there I still think Felicia Michaels is
gorgeous oh she's stolen yeah but no
she's gorgeous she's hilarious but I'm
just saying like I have to say the exact
every time we all hung Alex mean you me
and Felicia did a podcast like sanic
three times every time I was like - she
sold I'm in love
don't look [ __ ] good yeah yeah yeah
and she's a savage yeah yeah yeah hides
it but it was like in those days she
would have when they would book Bobby
Collins who was on fire he had to search
commercial Barbaro Bobby Collins worked
with the louis c.k and fort lauderdale
and when georgia was born in 2004 and
Bobby Collins rolled in and hiding the
man I've never seen Louisa was a big guy
to me but man he paid Bobby Collins
massive respect like was so grateful
that he came in yeah and don't Bobby's a
good dude man and Bobby Collins were
coming Monday Tuesday then
Felicia Michaels are coming Wednesday
and Thursday Friday and Saturday you
don't see that Jackie Flint I never
forget who the hottest comic was in the
country when I got into comedy you ready
yeah who's the guy great Garcia had on
that show from Boston what's the show
before My Name Is Earl we had was the
Raising Arizona was alone Anthony Clark
Anthony Clark when I got into County
Anthony Clark was the [ __ ] comic to
watch dude he he was tremendous at that
time what happened to him he moved that
that way and he became a television star
no but like he he what happened to him
like I haven't seen him in a while well
he was a fun guy Artie with bestop's
three people like we usually do when we
have three dollars no we think we know
everything about the world yeah some
people turn against you the network's if
I heard a story about him by the way
this is uh allegedly right we predict
ourselves yeah this isn't bad but uh
legal when he got on Boston Commons I
think was the first show we did it's
like a big show yes he did Boston
Commons he was in Boston at the time or
or Seattle or LA but is his brother
connected with a bunch of guys who were
starting a company and unlike you should
really invest in our company have a
little extra cash those two men so he
did and that company was Microsoft and I
heard he is
in full for the rest of his life you
never look at they say dice was one of
the original essence of Starbucks really
oh I think that was nice got hot
Brian's tunnel is just fine that's the
rumor hope who knows I never met that I
might matter I met dice I've actually
worked with dice I don't know dice but I
find him fascinating very fascinating
and when you hear his story of how he
started how is he wasn't even 18 and he
started as a Travolta impersonator yeah
and he would go to these mafia parties
and they would pay him 200 to do
Travolta you know it goes on and on I
mean he'd sit there and go jesus [ __ ]
christ and that was my point the
podcasting it's not like we're good at
podcasting it's that I paid my dues as a
comic well yeah and then I became a
storyteller later on and I figured my
niche out my niche wasn't going up there
and telling you that her [ __ ] stunk
like a fish or my dick or that I had her
ass that was nothing to do with it
my comedy was about what was in front of
me which was what was my life well I
mean personally I think comedians can be
are the best podcasters but there's a
lot of comedian that we've had them as
guests and they have their own podcasts
that are they can be the worst
podcasters to like you can I jump in and
say that like so like someone I thought
and by the way I hope he's on time I'm
talking [ __ ] I hope this everyone sees
that this is coming with love but like
like I someone I thought that would be
bad at podcasting would be Paulie
because because Paulie was a movie star
like in the 80s so like and there's such
a like an ingrained in doctrine like um
don't share too much you know type of
thing and then I saw him on Rogen I got
really excited huh I've always been a
fan of paulie's you know from when I was
I mean he was a movie star when I was in
high school so like I watched every one
of his [ __ ] movies and I know there's
a part of Holly that's deeper than what
maybe the public thinks so I saw him on
Rogen and it was maybe one of my
favorite Rogen appearances I've ever
seen and
start by talking about Europeans with
him here is a little talk about polish
oh did you guys pause the video yet no
oh
serious cuz I would love to see that
[ __ ] I would love to see that it was
such a great Rogen appearance and I was
like that's what I love about podcasting
I think him being vulnerable I think
it's better that the Rogen appearance is
the one that's out there really yeah did
you air though oh yeah what's the movie
that somebody says that we don't talk
about him Baltimore had a partner
he-who-must-not-be-named
no no we don't talk about him you watch
Harry Potter you call it [ __ ] upon Pauly
Shore direct you know I wonder if he
knows who I am as a man oh you don't
need to know nobody let's leave him a
message he shed maybe like he put on
speaker Joe Pauly Shore Joe Diaz always
signing on the Rogan podcast you forget
about me and [ __ ] [ __ ] we'll send
you a star you got in to see no man 3
you know you don't want to talk to me no
more call me back I miss you I love you
we just found a podcast live and we were
talking about here your parents on Rogue
and how great you are and [ __ ] you
showed up here with flip-flops on look
at all [ __ ] up but I love you I'm
taking the buy you call me back stay
black a kid wait if you have that audio
can we can it can it be something given
to friends that we can personalism do on
our place
it's in the deep deep we can we can we
can say what do we give like the angel
sheriff I guess Thursday what the truth
about podcasting is there's 50 comments
out there yeah and we've had Thomas on
here we thought what if I come on here
and blow the roof off and they've been
duds and then we've brought in regular
people on the you done sensational
there's a line in your life
and if you don't willing to go through
that line you're dead and podcast and
that's the one guys then there's the
guys that come on and look that one yet
and they looking and they go I've got a
radio for 23 years well when it plays
into you mister [ __ ] dinosaur man
alright mr. Clapp thesaurus whatever the
[ __ ] they are with two little hands once
again with the hands per se Rex where I
left off or other dinosaur your name we
that's why radios dead because you're
still using the phony voice and you're
still that that's not what people
looking for you're looking for a real
Nonna's conversation it's a shot in the
heart Eve that's exactly what this is
it's two people three people talking
[ __ ]
smoking dope I having a few cocktails
and anything goes you know when I listen
to a podcast and it's edited that's the
last time I was in touch I want to hear
everything that the guy slept if the guy
slipped and said [ __ ] spit because
something so let it be maybe he was in
the [ __ ] moment did you ever think
that that people are in the moment and
then when people are not talking and
they're talking about people and they
get excited they say things they
normally wouldn't say but it's not in
the [ __ ] abrasive way yeah it's not
meant for hey that's what I want to hear
I want to hear that [ __ ]
I want to hear when Lee farts I want to
hear when bird burps this is what a
podcast is and unless you're doing that
it's not gonna work and that in my world
and there's people will disagree with me
that's fine there's people that want
their podcast grew
like hey Novak doesn't like I thought
what I like I want to listen to a
podcast that any Minister the cops could
kick down the door this 90 minutes any
day you want to be doing a podcast and
we're gonna get swatted yeah that's true
gonna tell you my favorite part of
Rogen's podcast oh this is old school
Rogen you'll remember this do you
remember when that landline he had in
his room would ring and I used to love
that cuz I go oh yeah the phone's
ringing and he'd go [ __ ] that forgot to
turn it off he'd be like ah [ __ ] those
those things in part for me I'm excited
for like a podcast history class do me a
favor those are my fans I could teach it
yeah absolutely
two for a second okay or I want you to
click and Lenny Bruce out look I gotta
piss I want to piss real quick yeah
gonna get money finds this guy to the
right this if you don't make a movie
right left it don't matter it does
bullet let me get some shoutouts to my
girl crystal Oakes my main man in Jersey
looking out for me always
Mikey climb with the one by one podcast
my main man Paul gaultieri Randy
Funderburk Mike Dunn tenon Smith KCCI
grave and my brother from a different
mother always Jeffrey Collins was a
[ __ ] soldier of debt and I want to
try and congratulate my main man [ __ ]
talking laughs you finally got a job
he's putting things together
congratulating the business in
California soon he's coming on a mission
from debt he doesn't even know it yet I
told him last week that he's on call
yeah he might have to [ __ ] get in
that [ __ ] Hyundai and put the other
side on and bring a [ __ ] victim with
I mean it was saying and beside that is
beautiful time we got [ __ ] my main
man look for what was I saying if we
don't look for yeah just Lenny Bruce out
okay Lenny Bruce out okay
let's just start with that let me see
what you come up with I need to yes
please did you know my what's that you
know listen when I got into comedy I'm a
lot older than you guys and maybe a lot
younger is lab your minds I listen to
this stuff what happened to calm me I
learned to listen to calm me from
listening to albums
okay know that stand up oh you know that
was the first thing that popped up
saying over here yeah you know I learned
from listening to hounds like that right
there right there click to the first one
just click onto that alright let's say I
wasn't even born yet no before I want
you to tell me you stopped me if you've
seen it I'm going to piss on you
now
no he has so much acceptance see that I
can't take the vid out every time I say
I just started the gag once you know and
they just say let me just do it to talk
[ __ ] but now piss on his first thing
you'll do the rest of it they're
crackling because something is yelling a
sparkler in the air yeah that's the
album guys
yes sometimes I want you to put on
richard prize and some ice age right
there the fourth one down it was
something I did pause for one second so
the thing I'm obsessed with right now
Joey is the first word to come out of a
comic spell well let's let's uh let's
listen right I'm obsessed with it let's
listen what the [ __ ] you got tell me
let's air
[Applause]
[Laughter]
dude hit pause for one second I'm sorry
Lee but like that the thing I look about
with specials now is I go I go what are
the first words coming out of your mouth
cuz how you know come working on my
special I don't want to build up too
much but I go you don't want too much of
the like you know what's up Philadelphia
is everyone good here is everyone having
a good time you want like I did that on
my last pitch a lot I was like III rift
on you go to a restaurant how do you
like to get treated well scroll that
down till the end I want to see if they
got then why no me no no I'm the video
scroll down cuz maybe that that like
they said number one usual eulogy when
you go in there it'll give the titles
when a woman leaves you know on you when
you go back come on actually goodnight
kiss
you gonna give more beautiful our texts
for today no click up there could eat
before that I don't meets Dracula like
I'm dead you know how you want to be
treated brother yeah just click up to my
no meets Dracula Richard Pryor erased
Lenny Bruce hey your go you're [ __ ]
you know how do you like to be treated
when you're in a restaurant were you
wife I like to be served
no personally yeah the first one this is
the my nose this is what got me into
coming right here Freddie
here's 1970 guys this before rap oh yeah
offered honest he was [ __ ] killin guys
oh he's [ __ ] killin I click onto that
one up there he was shocked what Junior
holy [ __ ]
I love TVs this is it I know you guys
need to do specials now I love this [ __ ]
but I love CDs I love this [ __ ] this
manatees - I love this [ __ ] sound
click onto the exorcist and see what
that is I think you know the story about
the devil gets into this twelve-year-old
girl that was a low [ __ ]
see there wouldn't have been no movie
two-bit [ __ ] in it the movie would
have been about seven minutes long soon
as the devil spoke
[Applause]
well didn't have Blackpool talking like
this yet oh I left that [ __ ] house
that afternoon I had to walk like a mile
home but I can't stop thinking about
this I didn't know it's gonna be a
stand-up comic but this made me buy
other albums and you know it opened up
the [ __ ] door but this sound this is
why I started podcasting I missed this
I missed that pure laughter no HBO
presents Showtime but just a guy in a
bar that's why I love whenever I go
somewhere I see a Richard Pryor I'm I
buy it because it's as pure as when we
and I did it's either you or the priests
it wasn't planned we didn't talk about
it we didn't have a cover taken you told
me didn't know you're gonna say Lee goes
let's go down the brand got this thing
let's try it out it cost me 35 miles to
rent number of things that you guys all
bought to do live podcast yeah that was
it yeah the zoom we still used today I
rent that 50 right yes I did the spot
and it became the more one CD I'll
[ __ ] I don't and allured no don't no
stories no drama no big programming it
costs 40 hours if you listen to it today
you go Joey you know what man it sounded
that this sound like that I want you to
think I want you to listen this is why I
fell in love with the concept of the
podcast because I want this somebody hit
me up on Twitter today or yesterday
leave you don't say that I'm listening
to the podcast right now with two ladies
I'm knocking on your door saying that
you smoke a lot no I was one of the best
podcast in my life with Felipe if you
listen to it it's [ __ ] God or what
happened
via Felipe and the [ __ ] well
this other location we had on Burbank
Boulevard oh no I remember that place I
think no no no we barely had anybody
that we had three months there the table
was too big for the room there was a
small table Oh sometimes it's not the
place by in and out no no this was one
that we had the palace compared to this
we had this place I don't know AC no AC
we were there for three months those are
the earthquake there was a woman who was
pretending to be a what is it called
when he stamp things though every next
door yeah I have complained about the
reef they would bang no we weren't even
smoking and we weren't he was smoking it
was a [ __ ] nightmare but one of the
best things that was when she knocked on
the door because it felt like I was on
stage and the waitresses trick trade
fell over the glasses clown really
you're in the moment I love that yeah
you see a love that Stan won't try to
say to you so this is why this is the
style of this podcast we do this is the
only way I could do a podcast because I
don't want to fly at ESPN hey how are
you I love that shirt yeah well my
opinion on a journalist and [ __ ] you and
your [ __ ] opinion if I wanted your
opinion I'd turn on channel 18 and be at
home watching you're right yeah you know
I just hate I hate all that [ __ ] I
always so for me this was perfect this
is what I like I admire this I want you
to listen and think the cops are gonna
kick the doors in and arrest you for
listening to this that's what a podcast
means to me do you ever think about
recording that the the periscope part as
part of the podcast cuz watching you get
high and rant his one
my favorite things yeah listen don't
really to everything well is that down
YouTube everything yeah we do everything
sporadically man I wanna [ __ ] those when
you want a periscope yeah I can't do it
I can't you know you you can't stay out
of social media all day and left I don't
take your [ __ ] seriously it kills me
you gotta keep give them a [ __ ]
breather they're getting bombarded with
so much [ __ ] you can only give them so
much [ __ ] and then they go I listen we
take enough [ __ ] was a little Joey yeah
you know I try to get off two three days
something a day here a day there
you gotta get people [ __ ] breathing
it's amazing that what I use it for and
what other people use it for I'm really
amazes its amazes me - I use it
specifically to shoot those promo videos
I just all I do I love the videos with
the kids and yeah it's [ __ ]
phenomenom and cleveland I love [ __ ]
you get involved that [ __ ] throw [ __ ]
great you know why cuz it's better than
the fat [ __ ] that will not smoking pot
that's 50 years old don't go see him and
I'm Terry okay don't know but at least
it's green I'm saying like that that's
the stuff that pisses me off
and now it makes everybody a director
that's what's happening to our business
will happen to our businesses and made
everybody a director you've got that
right so they would do two little
[ __ ] film show up to Paramount and
they get together and go in a second
this [ __ ] hump head I gotta give him
the 3/4 of a mil to shoot a movie I got
this [ __ ] idiot from down the corner
on Hollywood Boulevard he got a degree
from the Hollywood film it's into the
world over the front out a big youtube
channel yes
let's give him order and this is what
happens and the last couple lights we've
killed two hours in here hi watching
movie clips and there was real width I
showed Lee movie clips where you see
what a director is best thought involved
while you're watching the movie
Hun's of Thornton Wow like I showed in
the scene last night from a movie called
daddy with a harmless on teh where's
like half the movie and be gray this
make something of all time what's what's
the Mexicans name here oh no no let's go
on old school one forgot that was enough
cross 110 Street he's in a movie revenge
which is [ __ ] phenomenal it was the
good-looking guy The Bodyguard Oh Kevin
Costner Anthony Quinn that's what I'm
talking about [ __ ] that how do you
giggle about burger I pick the white guy
I'm jumping dollars I need you [ __ ]
hippie way God spin you Anthony Quinn is
my name on that pillow
what pillow it is why did those monkey
ax is this Bert oh he's here listen
there's a frog with that is I forgot
though right - [ __ ] white shark
[ __ ] blow up is a frog with your name
did you know that the bird no I think
you're thinking a Burton Ernie right
yeah yeah he's got a fuzzy but there's a
make a difference so you got a name they
share with a muppet you're worried about
your name on a pillow up you got some
pair of [ __ ] balls kid you know hey
Gopi I just saw I just saw my name on a
pillow
I've been looking at and I was like I
thought of a serendipity I [ __ ] up you
brought your own I was gonna ask that
but I got some Cheetos and good Japanese
snacks no there's no you can't have
snacks
we can't eat stuff here we go crazy we
begin nuts uh all I do is eat snacks
right now I'm thinking about leaving a
Deathstorm that hungry when I got up to
my highest like the out go to the
grocery store my entire car would just
be diet soda and snacks
so are these Death Star's yum yummy yeah
if you eat one or two they're pretty
good going studying five years they
start to fail
it's just hard to eat five to ten
gummies at once really yeah
you guys gonna do a bag at night
probably for the bigger one - no what
was it like when you first started
eating these ooh big we got free met
Joey no no no yeah
so you how did you find Joey Facebook
well I've had him for the Rogan but then
I contacted my facebook and then he was
like yeah let's do something let's see
if we connect I think he kind of Heidi
he asked me what my ideas were and then
we just hung out at the haha for like a
month
at night and that was crazy I was like
someone and someone asked me today on
Twitter right before the podcast if I've
ever been starstruck on the podcast and
I was thinking about it and I was
starstruck meeting Joey I was petrified
look yeah well yeah I I don't know I've
never bad never been I'm always struck
by people who are on the news before I
move to LA and then like it was weird
and then I've been with Joey it's kind
of there's nothing that can really faze
iam fun wait had you ever heard of me
before you met me yeah for real yeah of
course you want and welcome before you
on here problem yeah that's amazing what
happened in there yeah we did go pretty
hard in here so yeah so yeah man we then
we did Matt flavors world what's
powerful it was world we did he did he
had a camera from gabriel iglesias and
he did little blogs and stuff and he
gave him the to me once a week and I hit
them together really yeah we'd be like
15 of them something like that and then
he called me one that at work and like
midnight said would you like to shoot a
documentary in New York is that how you
guys started with the is with the the
doc was that one of the first thing yeah
go ahead
I thought he was like a film major and
that was that no I thought he was a
know-it-all mm-hmm he shows up and
everything we've
[ __ ] stab the one we made it happen
I was an anything major he kept calling
me the director from Israel never did
anything the director from his weapons I
like Joey tell me like that what the
first thing like when I was like
brand-new he told me to lie to people
like puts helping me from Israel and I
can't speak Hebrew or like even pretend
this big piece but you've never got a
Bar Mitzvah yeah well yeah but they do
that ramp that little bird smile if
they're healing honest beekeeper they
laters yeah I guess you could you know I
shall how many [ __ ] movies those
shoes I'd sit there and watch these
[ __ ] morons make a big deal about
[ __ ] yeah and I would sit there and go
this is how I would block this right but
all those things I know right let me
practice in my head I would block this I
would make this guy move across and you
know was the last resort
I'd be like two steps or something yeah
you know it don't take a [ __ ] genius
and don't think well [ __ ] genius I've
been on [ __ ] CBS shows that the
directors are calmly legend me you meet
the guy he's a [ __ ] sleeping pill and
then you try to improvise and they
[ __ ] tell you you can't dude you know
you see that's what we're talking about
the driver yeah about acting jobs and
how at one point you get here and that's
what you strive for is these little
acting jobs and you're gonna maybe do a
couple of them and then you're like I
ain't doing this no more or if I don't
this is how I'm gonna do yeah like I
would enjoy like I would enjoy acting I
think more if I knew everything there
was to know like I want to know if I can
take like other takes and and like if I
can improv like I remember Mike Epps was
saying that he'd just would go in and do
it the way he did it [ __ ] him and I was
like I wish I had no nuts I would draw
it the way they wanted to do he go you
go to the audition
go to the audition they give me the
[ __ ] roll the first [ __ ] today
you're supposed to be there you calls at
2:00 in the afternoon
yeah you look at the call sheet see what
time they're actually gonna be there if
it's at 7:00 they're paying you number
one number two you're professional yeah
you go down there three four hours early
and one they block and catch the
director and this is exactly what's
gonna happen
hey how you doing Tony Burke rush Hey I
loved your audition tape
obviously I'm [ __ ] here [ __ ] it
wasn't like they out of that [ __ ] and
then they're like yeah is there anything
special you want me to plan you say that
to him right you keep that to yourself
whatever you make a [ __ ] joke
whatever you know they they they loved
how what you did okay let me ask them
number two what do you want from me and
they'll go well I want you to do the
scene you did exactly the way I like I
was blown away sometimes how people go
like I got that scene right off the cuff
and then they will go we'll work on this
you know I would only ask him today what
do you want from me [ __ ] today what
do you expect from there from the
[ __ ] character yeah you know I tried
to give him let that [ __ ] window so
that dick gets are like I know what I'm
doing you know very the via tell them
what you are from the character they get
the [ __ ] Apple and they eat and they
think Philippe then what the [ __ ]
they're doing and then number four is a
number three ask him if he wants any
special requests now you're in his world
now you gotta ask em can I ask you a
question I'm not trying to be rude I'm
here for you I did I have no comedy
scheduled my wife's got the kids how
many takes do we do for age and the guy
really tell you those why just you know
Adam Sandler he does one from the script
one for him one for you
Clint Eastwood does dope yeah there's
some [ __ ] people who would just
[ __ ] bro there's some guys you work
with that medium-range lab wards their
first big film with Fox or something
and they dress their kids over there is
nothing I could do
22 scene if you know there was a couple
years ago I shot a commercial for a big
Daddy I [ __ ] snapped on that set Go
Daddy Go Daddy
I [ __ ] snapped on that [ __ ] set the
director was just a dick yeah just a
dick you got all the shots you got all
the shots how many [ __ ] shot you want
was that's the one we're getting like a
flower thrown in your face yeah and they
thought it was cute and I know what
somebody's trying to be cute ain't that
much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] I know when some
directors trying to make you the best
was the [ __ ] what's the people of
what you like what's a fast-food worker
you like all oh yeah cause my least
favorite director called I don't have an
idiot
what because the [ __ ] car had no
brakes when they connected then interior
whites and canvas for the car well he
dissing it through the brakes so the
first time the car rolled they said
they'd fix it the second time the car
rolled and he said something else
I told [ __ ] you [ __ ] this I went off
the other it was two of us playing like
Italian mob hit the other guy is still
my friend
really till this day because how I went
off and that directly at the end of the
wreck that apologized to me like [ __ ]
fire me when I give a [ __ ] yeah well the
[ __ ] you [ __ ] do you think you are
you know he can't hit but everybody was
scared of him he had an assistant that
would come up to you and talk instead of
him I think there's lots about talent
more about yeah no no no no it knowing
the right uniform to wear on yeah yeah
oh no listen if and there's some movies
you're going to say you know the
director is run away yeah so the Hat
with the feather 22 tattoos all the way
the [ __ ] wrist
Double Dhamaal done a wife-beater
t-shirt
what's the pants they wear whether it
was shorts was sort of a show the tattoo
on a can look up rebounds yeah
it's the same look you could see or if
you have a woman director you really
have a problem you have to dye the hair
you know no it's real all women
directors listen we're talking about the
content director 'aa cross the board no
no no no no I worked with a woman I'd
send it to you the painless pilot that
was brilliant she taught me a lot who I
worked on you know was a good director
dog you know director being on The
Sopranos sketches from MADtv oh the wife
from married with children not was Bundy
no the other one of the lesbian yes yeah
he directed me on MADtv sweeter than pie
but there was something I did that I
worked with a woman but I got there the
whole set was cliche oh the fact that
was somebody always working recently
that contacted me able to their resume
looked at their web page and I go oh my
god I know who I'm dealing with
and I just know it and she hit me with
an offer and I had I knew I knew the
kind of office she was gonna go I'd be
with and then I told her no I couldn't
do it but you know the look there's a
look a certain look that a woman gets
when she wants you to know she's a
director or a producer or and it's so
[ __ ] the cliche guys it sucks
I worked with like women that just
natural and a [ __ ] tremendous the
ones that want to be artsy fartsy I
worked at two gay directors one time
they were [ __ ] solid as [ __ ] - we
made a movie called the mesos what was
that about - man let me take some time
on how I found with a weird Hollywood
works first season uh Sopranos it's a
[ __ ] head yeah it's a [ __ ] head
every network orders a mafia show one
way or the other they're getting
thousands of mob shows thousands of my
related shows I know these two gay dudes
in Hollywood and they ride this script
about you know like gay theatres I'm
Santa Monica Boulevard where they play
gay porn sometimes oh yeah you guys
talking about that's two hits were sort
of what's-his-name from got busted yeah
it's a bit so superb operator yes - Bob
there that's there the pink big laces on
yeah where's the headquarters and they
did something else everything was very
gay ish in orange and there was these
two brothers who were gay but they
gangstas and nobody knows that they
gangsters that tremendous hitmen yeah so
it's like pay only no way the type deal
so nobody knows these two guys are gay
they're not the flaming type gay guys
they're just the ones down another big
they go to clubs and terminate his shell
and he wrote this up and took the TABC
and maybe see all the [ __ ] scrap
right okay they they jack around a
little bit and he gets wind that The
Sopranos were not happy with big [ __ ]
in real life that they already know that
he puts he had asked for a bunch of
money the second season real and that he
was gonna kill Bob like once he's been
oh the rumor is on Susannah he's got
money you get killed off when some of
those shows uh what the cricket you ask
for that raise is the quicker they kill
you off so these two gay guys who were
sweethearts I still talk to the one guy
Joe contact went to New York and met
with Vincent Pastore
and they got Vincent passport money to
shoot a pilot about two gay guys that
again win the Mafia and that way and
they own the theatre yeah and that's
their headquarters and they loaned out
money
that's something else I was pretty funny
the guy did do a good job yeah without
just being like we weren't flaming [ __ ]
you know yeah not to like that he did
something I can't remember what the [ __ ]
it was
and I was gonna Fox in audition no you
ready for this one
yeah they shoot a pilot ABC says God
Bush we don't want the thing or they
didn't shoot the pilot so everybody was
laying there with a dick in their hand
they took it everybody else everybody
else passed on it these two guys didn't
wanna [ __ ] just lose the project so
they sold it to fight Fox Searchlight
whatever the [ __ ] that is
and big [ __ ] didn't want to do it for
that price really so we all audition
from the scratch everything from Frank
Stallone to NICTA Toro really to any guy
you saw in Goodfellas Johnny roast beef
Wow and I got it like the two guys who
got like if you would have told me it me
and this other guy were gonna get it I
went all against it me and I mean there
were stars in that room yeah the guy
that got shot the eyeball and the
Godfather was in that room oh yeah yeah
no no there was a thousand Italian stars
in that room when I got the call back I
was a [ __ ] shocked yeah and this is
the funny see you don't know what see
people have no idea what the route is
here I had at that time one of the
smartest guys I ever had working with in
the entertainment business at that time
he was a genius in fact he just texted
me about a week ago and he said that he
listened to a podcast where myself and
Jimmy Schubert was there discussing him
to use he was a brought tears to his
eyes how proud he was of us he was mine
Jimmy Schubert's manager he had six
killers then nobody Norma and he would
live and die for you like if I'd I'd
love them to Billy Gardell
at hearts maybe three months ago really
and Billy asked me because you ever talk
to Jeff in it
Jeff was the one that got Billy going so
it had I don't know how you know how did
you meet how did you meet Billy oh I
know Billy since 1998
for real yeah we used to go to ice storm
Billy got down and Billy Gardell for
those you don't know is a different mic
and mine from my kamalii
I know Billy from the estimate and 98
being a coach to the horses with him at
4:00 in the afternoon having a girl
that's comedian girl that's still in
town broke up and we went there me him
and Stan or maybe a few other be really
yeah I sweet sweet sweet take me back to
them like what was it like back then
like you wanted to say this from oh yeah
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I really
give props to this guy the problem with
this guy was that I wasn't strong enough
and he was getting me into [ __ ] rooms
that my knees were prickle like into our
dishes like he going down there you
reading with Travolta today but that
type of [ __ ] like he's 98
I just got here I'm a prednisone blow
fixed my Toit and I'm gonna tease or
dishes I could not handle but bro this
guy always had a plan yeah he's like
this is what's going on so I go should I
do this project it was like 250th that
flat it was 500 for the weekend if they
went over a certain amount of hours they
would give me an extra hundred bucks but
dude said they would take care of me I
asked him like a brochure I'd do this he
goes Joey the sopranos is the hottest
show on TV right now they're working a
thousand projects you need this tape he
goes I know these guys they're shoot on
something they should I shot it came out
great got into a bunch all our faith gay
film festivals I got a couple meetings
from it but he gave me a call and then
he was she's gonna know he read for that
movie about Chuck Barris the man moving
him
show he was the CIA yeah like that she
made me go he made me go over for this
role that I didn't want to [ __ ] read
so I got my going in there but then
looking for two Mexicans they don't
listen you're gonna take this role
because you're not gonna get this he
goes like that they already have an
offer on I want please oh that doesn't
matter I want you to go in there and
rock her world
why don't give her an accent rock her
world listen to me bro I went in there
and rocked her world she called me back
I went to producers I didn't get the
role but on the way out the second time
I went to pursue make me go to producers
once then twice which meant she liked me
on the way out she goes it was great to
see you thank you to come she does
regretted so what happens here finish
because I want you to keep in touch with
me she doesn't he tell me doing new
projects I want you to hit me up this
lady was like [ __ ] huge yeah this
place but she wasn't here she wasn't
even based on LA and you know forget
what her name is she was based out of
New York if you go to mine DiBiase her
name was within four weeks I get the
tape from the mezzos Jeff Gallen was the
manager he called me those was that
mezzos tape in awhile they said they
won't give it to me and go sit around
let me call you back
next thing you know she can call me but
he goes listen they want you to go by
the house and pick up two scenes I went
by the house I picked up two scenes I
said a game to Jeff Jeff sent them to
some guy some guy [ __ ] pup pup pup
pup pup this is 2003 Jeff sends me and
he goes Joey I'm sending this to the
lady you read for yeah well what did you
do what to analyze that
what did she who put me in now who was a
casting director in that click on
analyze that hold tight okay
and in fact her assistant is now a big
casting director here well she put me in
something about two years ago and she
was casting Whitney oh really yeah no no
no that being a how life that works
that's crazy
I never thought that you'd read for
something and you wouldn't be right for
it they go he's not right for this but
he's right for other things well I
always thought I was it's a [ __ ]
cover-up story yeah but you know when
somebody is telling you the truth
you'll get the handle for it that your
agent you when you're walking out of the
room there's times that the producers
already have somebody
yeah but she's trying to save them to
$1,000
do you understand me you go and then do
a good job but am i enough to say wrong
$200,000 Ellen Chenoweth Ellen Chenoweth
oh wow in general you know that is see
who helped each other with cast ellen
gentleman's daughter is the girl that
was in wicked-looking Ellen's channel
with what she's casted read him out
loudly okay do myself on the top of the
bottom whatever you watch is a retelling
him uh-huh
she's a savage Alan Chenoweth and mostly
the Niro movies oh yeah a lot of o
brother where art thou analyzed that
Mona Lisa smile you know is this a horse
whisperer wag the dog will lead a flea
in no no she's heavy-duty bro yeah I
kept in touch your daughter hot dogs
tail who's her dog a Bronx Tale is great
who's her daughter I'm still going down
terms of endearment come on dear me no I
don't worry about who the [ __ ] I'm oh no
no no no no no this is kind of no she's
84 credits that's crazy keep going up
keep going up and then Kristen bow-bow
Kristin Chenoweth
find out it's like Kristin Chenoweth
she's one that started a wicked
I think wicked was a big biggest play on
Broadway Kristin Chenoweth is in wicked
am i right I don't know click it I
didn't I just knew it click it is it a
click
Oh
then maybe I'm wrong I missing but that
those meso stupid tapes to identify
flowers he sent them to Ellen Chenoweth
I can't analyze that really that's how
he knew always knew what was and I would
bang it out listen man I'm gonna be in
the [ __ ] New York to extents tool
comedy if [ __ ] Rascals and him calling
me going you got any tape see and I'm
like Jay goes bring the tape over to
what's-his-name they're casting a show
called The Sopranos or something what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
I'm not a sing instead of dropping the
tape off the soprano Sopranos I drop the
tape off it like Roger Paul and two
other bummy [ __ ] comedy babe I can't
sing the generator strong Jeff Gallen
buzz bro
yeah Jeff Gallen got me out for oh my
god oh my god imma go on time Jeff
Gallen had these guys put together a
game show around me where I was the host
and you had a burglarized somebody's
house and [ __ ] you they was just
crazy and they got so at NBC because
they getting ready for this strike this
was crazy and Joe came with me
this is 97 98 one thousand two thousand
one we were doing something one night I
go Joe I got a [ __ ] call back you
gotta drive me and he was best we went
he walked in there with me showed me how
to dude that's how cool that
[ __ ] here he was already hosting
free effect and he's like let me show
you how to do this and I did it and then
they went with a [ __ ] black dude and
then they shot the pilot and nope none
that ever call them racist and a black I
break in and out
black dude a [ __ ] mix dude yeah some
[ __ ] like this so what else has been
going on in your life nothing is the
road I think I worked too much but my
part my podcasts been doing really well
a few relationship podcasts how many
times a week once a week on Wednesday I
just won one podcast a week I did it I
did there was a period where I was doing
two a week and I just noticed am i I was
losing my ratings were cutting in half
like it wasn't like if I'd release it on
Wednesday I release it every night at
Tuesday at like 6 p.m. so that it's out
there Wednesday morning for everybody
cuz that's the word libsyn kind of like
cut is it cut off but uh and I also kind
of fine-tuned it you're so funny my
biggest podcasters were always when we
you come over we party me ralphing me
Tommy mute ami my dad me and Tommy amber
me and Ari and and run is easy like
those are my biggest podcasts so I kind
of just looked at the numbers and I was
like well [ __ ] if those are the biggest
ones I'll just keep doing that so I was
like alright so now if I do my podcast I
do it Monday nights at 8:30 is when I
tape it and we just and we just have a
few cocktails one life on two finest
moments in podcasting believing that had
nothing to do with me
I got a call one night that we're gonna
go over to raha to Bert crisis out Bert
calls me to his house he invites me
always very gracious and he just come
over at a certain time I'd like for you
to do a podcast at the time I took Bert
was Johnny professional I got over that
20 minutes too early he invites me into
his mancave he offers me something we
sit they gave me that weed from that you
like the sativa from Betsy Crocker
whatever Phyllis Diller bought a joint
and we sat there and waited for Ralphie
May we got a call about 8:15 saying that
Ralphie was coming up over the hill
let's remember you gonna buck right sure
he's not coming over there anyway listen
it's Lila clock and like no listen calm
again and ask away is so now he calls
again you call him you call them you
call him I go Bert I think that's a
reality that we might as well stop
decimals and the phone rings and Ralphie
wears like I'm stuck I'm walking and I'm
just pulling up and buy a gas station is
that I've driving the whole address a
pie place across the street on to
Milwaukee and what he's closed her and
Bert direction to where he goes but
anyway I got that equality the broadcast
was supposed to start at 8:00 it's 10:00
the [ __ ] tent so Ralphie comes in
smoking a vapor pen I'm sitting there
Bert we're having a blast it's a great
podcast we go back and forth finally
it's mint it's 12:30 at night the girls
asleep it's time to go we hug we walk
out I walk I follow Bert out right I
follow Berta hello Lawton I can't see it
my tumblr follow the [ __ ] leaders his
house but all of a sudden I assume
Ralphie's Buckeye made and I just hear
ba ba ba ba ba and we both turn around
shocked in this rough you're inhaling
your daughter's Dow up
it was just like a meteor hit one of
those Chinese villages it was a show
that we could not laugh listen you
cannot laugh at your friend okay no no
no this listen this certain situation is
when you laughing a friend you did
something stupid they gave you a Chinese
instead of Italian you know but there's
just certain times where if something
happens to a friend of yours and you
cannot put that time in that time period
pal again no listen to me he falls what
was it please but it was a it was um it
was a beach chairs sleeve the kind that
you can fold up and put into a sleeve
and then open up then turn into a chair
and he felt on top of them and literally
like he [ __ ] them up or your hair is
like you thought there was 40 kung-fu
masters in karate chop award you heard
each karate teacher would go down it
looked like someone just destroyed a
tent
oh and just they were all flat oh my god
oh my god
I was like another cheapest [ __ ] they
weren't like a super-expensive that's
why he went right through yeah he went
right doing they were the [ __ ] tubes
once you get it he's like man I'm a
hundred bucks for him I was like Ralphie
they cost five bucks but he was yeah he
was [ __ ] high [ __ ] walking out of
that house we had to pick him up yeah
that's no picnic the whole time I'm
walking out with him and I got that ball
of laughter stuck like if it's right
behind my heart that Danielle I was
supposed to let out like that was a yell
when that happened at that point but I
was supposed to let out that I didn't
live without and I just wanted to go my
car I just want to get to my car and he
kept fast boy he's going tomorrow meet
me at the Country Club
we'll get the kids swimming all this
show my Ralphie I gotta go
the bathroom really bad listen guys I
got in the car that door wasn't shut for
minutes and I just let out laughter it
was a just a comprehensive oh my god the
car sideways like I was like aha
as I gotta run the call I call Burt he
wouldn't answer the tow hash Burt was
that the funniest [ __ ] thing it was
you had ever seen yo I'm still laughing
from his Umberto I and him were walking
out very like and Janicek wah like it
was death there was no big deal
we're just walking out of here like we
walked out of here a thousand times and
also you hear blah blah
we were on like like I remember I'm ever
getting done that and said in the man
cave
and looking at that chair just going how
do I explain that to the girls I've had
so many run-ins with Ralphie that I know
that are making me laugh so hard I'm in
my favorite one is we went he's gonna
hate that I'm saying this we went to
love the first story like even I know
what Ralphie's saying in his head
right now in this story we go to would
do Alanis with Paul Young Ron and
Ralphie and I are the comedian's
Ralphie's headline and I'm kind of open
I'm not kind of open I'm definitely
opening for them I'm doing 20 minutes
Ralphie's doing an hour so every [ __ ]
night we go out to dinner every night we
go out to dinner
Ralphie orders a [ __ ] grab bag of
beautiful stuff to eat and he pays for
it every [ __ ] night so the last night
Leanne's like hey we got to put our
credit card down we can't let Ravi pay
he's paid for like [ __ ] five meals so
like lunches too you know so so we go to
snow oh we got to know how I think some
whatever that not know how so boo subbu
subbu whatever the sushi restaurant in
that place is we go there and I stopped
the lady before we even get the meal I
go hey give her my credit card the big
guy doesn't pay sick okay so she comes
up with a bill at the end of the night
and she hands the directly me and Rafi
goes pay I got that I was like no Rafi
already paid and he starts giggling
hearty [ __ ] he goes oh you don't want
that Playa you don't want that I was
like Ralphie no I got it I got it I open
it and I see the bill and it's $1,200
and I go and and he sees my eyes realize
I can't afford it like he's like I can't
afford it I can't afford I'm featuring I
can't afford it no one can afford it he
sees my eyes and he starts laughing this
Ralphie laughs and then Leanne says how
much is it and I go shut the [ __ ] up
that's how much it is I'll play you just
done [ __ ] up you just let me pay for
it I was I wasn't willing to spend what
we paid for in a tip like the tip was
[ __ ] 240 bucks I wasn't willing to
spend that eight and then I went and
that first thing I did I went out right
up to the bank machine and I pulled out
$1,000 and put it all black and lost
well I [ __ ] went down like $4,000 at
night and then I got into a huge [ __ ]
fight oh and then Ralphie's I tried to
set it on radio a time robbers
yeah we didn't eat 1,200 pounds of sushi
done ever done thousands of sushi
you drank $1,000 for the booze we had
$200 worth of sushi I was like Alan Oh
Ralphie well it's someone late for an
8:00 they were bringing out dolphins
like this is all we got left
oh okay so I totally the other day when
Ralphie first hit it was very fun to see
he's a sweetest guy in the world man
listen when he was broke he was doing
some amazing things I've always loved
that kid yeah we were talking last night
you know about for Houston food and I
said listen you guys they were talking
about K so I'm like I'll tell you one
don't wing bomb and then go why not
you're being there I go you know why
because I haven't got where alpha when
he first moved here and there was 10 of
them from Houston and then we get
together every night this was when Doug
gave ground for the apartment on Gardner
Doug Stanhope had an apartment on
constant Sun Gardner no or the apartment
on the street where 7-eleven isn't on
Sunset Boulevard you know I'm talking
about yeah the 7-eleven jump the block
after that was nicked Apollo and Mitch
Hedberg lived on that block the block
after that was Ralphie the block after
that was Josh walk in 1998 that's how it
was all right that's how it was he was
on cursed on or something like that then
there's though whatever and then there's
Gardner that's for Ralphie lived and
Vista is with Josh wolf lived this was a
great khali neighborhood and let me tell
you some as broke as he was Ralphie he
would leave the Comedy Store and invite
you to his house and he would deep-fry a
turkey in the backyard
you've eaten deep-fried turkey at 5:30
in the morning with mashed potatoes and
stuff and player yeah he would go back
to his house and cook for us they were I
was totally they used to drive to
Houston 24 hours straight to bring back
Bloody Mary Mix and puts the beer they
drink shiner boss not about yeah that's
how crazy they were cuz Jodie or Celine
rest her soul snaily she died recently
about six months ago rest her soul they
were all friends or Alfie yeah Ralphie
knew Stacy from the comedy club and it
Salim that Ralphie stay with a wall they
were getting ready to move to LA and Joe
these are comic from houston middle they
all drove up we after that John West
thing came up with a man John Wesley
after that [ __ ] a bunch of the houston
comics came up and they had their own
little community really and they would
get together and it was always the same
arguing oh I went to this [ __ ] place
it says Texas barbecue the place sucks I
said give it up when you go to Texas
that's we need barbecue when ya here and
you just feeling it rip the [ __ ] off for
you neckla
my wife she's from the south like your
wife it nobody complains more than
number so when she tries to hit me with
something over walk walk in from the
South correct yeah do we go to that
barbecue place and alter this town the
same [ __ ] difference
yeah that's why don't what you cooked in
human food we had that we were in Tampa
Airport we went to La Loche Colombia in
Tampa Airport and I said Tilly and I
said you know I know it's an airport but
this is legit Cuban food like we're in
Tampa they're not having like this is
Cuban people making this food and we had
Cuban food she had big a deal arroz con
pollo and not by a rope of yeah and then
we had croquettas and and Cuban
sandwiches I bought I just bought it all
but Spanish rice and white rice and
black beans and Lena got so [ __ ] into
it for
birthday the other day she was like I
want Cuban food so we went to LA to burn
a Cubana have you been there
no where is it so ah yeah it's not the
best oh nothing I got a call next time
yeah yeah yeah as soon as you walk in
there you smell the food how bad news I
took Lee in there one time we walked
that wasn't it you and I having that's
me mean you mean Jerry Rocha walked in
there you know it took a little too long
to get to the table and before I got to
the table I know I think we should get
out of there you know one day I had a
little bit like a regular driver he
picked me and Lee up for a get ahead
with Doug when he gave me his number I
called him for an airport run when they
left my phone is gone I called them
because I'm rather on the call he was he
said he was a Cuban dude well now a lady
comes back with my phone but he also
brought me a Cuban sandwich from that
place do they use those ah it was yeah
it's not Cuban bread the only the only
thing I've ever gotten there was a
chicken rice right I was important was
it so bad to me I tasted okay because
it's only chicken rice but yeah they
probably didn't do it right they didn't
know arroz con pollo isn't the way they
said that the way they do it is a little
different than one the way I had it in
Tampa growing up in Tampa growing up
there was a presentation to it you know
to red peppers on the sides uh over the
side they really wanted to open up some
plantains around the side to do the
gooey ones not the hard ones
yeah the gooey one usually calls for you
know if you don't really cure for this
area I'll tell you what to where to go
and what to get where do we go around
here you go over the hill to Silver Lake
to a place called and look what you need
or now cochinita manually I'll cut you
need to when you get yourself tipping it
is my favorite oh yeah it's good there
because he is good there but my favorite
this is the place I used to cane in my
wedding
will he understand me what's the name of
this place again I'll put unique dog but
what I did was I only got the poor
chunks with the white rice and the black
beans smoking smoke really when I took
my wife this last time when date night
and we ordered the Cuban fried rice
listen if you like he's close fried rice
get the fried rice in this place really
Jesus Christ off 500 views four stars
I'm in I'm going there tomorrow yelping
- you're worse than my little [ __ ]
[ __ ] over here he goes on Yelp
ray came though the bathroom well Yelp
they have some bathrooms on Yelp
go go check it out what someone special
Amaro we our local boy oh we got your
ground beef with potatoes and ours and
flea holic allow red beans oh [ __ ]
we we might be doing road trip I kind of
want to go with you guys that you have
only gotten a late night flight I can't
go in the morning that's the best time
to go but I'm 130 of beat we could leave
here 130 be down there I supposed to be
an Anaheim tomorrow for what like that's
not happening willing a Cuban food call
hello hi um the conference has been
canceled and they want a conference they
gotta pay you then I come over here to
see yes in fact as a matter of fact your
song conferences as we speak right now
the next one is September 8th over here
at the how they have expressed you'll be
doing your own come up with some
podcasting
what's that exactly farmer allows for
these [ __ ] jerk calls to come and
learn nothing from people haven't done
come on I'm just gonna tell [ __ ]
Thursday's carne con Papa's a very nice
boy our sound was Friday and I mean his
paella Valencia pie is a [ __ ] into
lettuce pork chops every every day
[ __ ] kidding every day at our high
school we had a the pollo Mia tremendous
for every day every day we have
then [ __ ] in high school every because
we have Cuban
all Cuban women I've man I'm I must have
eaten that I must have had could you get
you get a every day you get black beans
of rice no matter what was they are
serving they always made black beans or
rice and they always made like once a
week there was every meal we had was
Cuban food for all because it was all
Cuban women cooking in our kitchen so
every day you can get black beans rice
no matter what it was spaghetti you
still could get black beans arise and
the Palomita you could always get that
man I must have had that every and then
you had Krispy Kreme Doughnuts in the
morning just created any brand and
Krispy Kreme Doughnuts stay warm
no not warm but they were fresh like
they were still there were still yet to
light those [ __ ] off and number
two not to change this concept of the
possible we're talking about food or
whatever yeah just to get this wrapped
up
you also have listen I did the Rogan
podcast man between you and I as friends
and gently in the church people listen
to it whatever you liked it I'm just
kind of ashamed by it I was kind of
ashamed that rogue and let it go by the
whole lot oh that Rogan let it go there
but doors podcast I laughed I was I'm
gonna stop you I was on the treadmill so
I said when the Brogan's part got
started I said there's gonna be three
plus hours of of something I want to see
but three of my favorite human beings
just [ __ ] and getting high and
drinking and I was like I'm in so I said
I got on the treadmill and I'm gonna
start watching and it there was a slow
build the first hour was like a slow
build nine minutes hour 30 minutes was
like a you know getting warm everyone's
getting a little bit of a buzz man there
was a part where I am holding on to the
sides of my treadmill doubled over
laughing and I start tweeting Joey Diaz
is killing me right now
killing me I I was on the treadmill for
the entire [ __ ] podcast walking and
running not running the whole time but
walking and running so I'm listening it
was one of my favorite it was one of my
favorite podcast I've ever listened to
that you were so funny
that I called Tom right through the
conversation we were having about later
I called Tom immediately when I was out
after I was like that I was like what
tell me about it like just tell me about
it it was like Joey's the [ __ ]
next-level man he's the funniest guy
that we know we are we've been doing
this for six years now yeah you know
this is this is what I do two nights a
[ __ ] week and I'm trying to write a
book so these memories are fresh in my
mind
crazy [ __ ] things I bring up from the
dead like oh my god you know I was
telling me I'm selling my wife today
that and my mom's feeling at the wake
a best friend but white powder in her
nose
there's 200 people in the thing it's the
second night and she goes I have a
something don't like half the people and
I go sorry
and she wasn't telling you and your
mother didn't like them neither she one
up by the casket and in broken English
is like gotta have your attention please
if you've listened enough enough that I
see a lot of you people having a good
time drinking there's a lot of people in
this room that you didn't like the nor
at the nor them like you do me a favor
Fletcher's bring it the [ __ ] out here
okay I got [ __ ] for days I still hearing
so what the [ __ ] just happened
that's the thing about you that makes
you different than that I think but then
again you met with what to them you're
the [ __ ] whatever for me Jesus for a
book you were the number one party
kidding [ __ ] Tampa Florida this [ __ ]
and he people were driving up eight
hours just to have a drink with you some
[ __ ] yeah but i'm not i'm but yeah but
taking this of your life matters you
know on stage i talk about how i had a
childhood i even know my mom died and
stuff I still remember calling a Dunkin
Donuts my white cast and put my dick on
the glass
when to the child into the counter put
my dick on the glass and ordering
doughnuts and then order the doughnut
from underneath and the way they would
see a dick
that's childhood no matter what was
going on with my [ __ ] life you know
I'm glad I'm glad I wasn't one of those
kids that came out to LA and at 27 had a
lot of heat and everyone was like
imagine I did have a lot of heat at 27
but I'm glad I wasn't the guy that like
I can I like not to but like I'm glad
that I had to struggle and then I got
had to that I didn't that I'm glad about
that that when we all got into
podcasting we were all looking for
something and we were hungry for
something and we all did something at
theirs at the right time for us and if
you look if this podcasting goes away
tomorrow I'm cool I'm cool with this
yeah I'm cool I was cool I learned a big
lesson I learned a very big lesson and I
had assumptions and this is something
that you cannot doubt me up cuz I have
my friend over there and I'll tell you
every assumption I had we sign out when
you look on his cup were like you're a
guy that desi never seen water for every
assumption I've had with you has come
true as specimens come to podcasting I
saw the growth I was on the road you're
on the road you see the interest yeah
you see the interest but number one
thing people say to me is hey thank you
for the free content oh all the time I
had a forklift and I listened to you and
Joey Diaz for three hours
and you guys got me to lunch and you're
like dude thought dude you know madness
yeah tremendous that's the best
compliment I can get I've been in New
York City about to take the ferry this
is great I would indeed hope in whoever
Sam and I [ __ ] take a cab to whatever
I'm staying and we Hawking so I take the
ferry oh when I left there it's freezing
something goes hey I'm listening to you
right now it's the greatest feeling the
world
we start talking and he goes you
wouldn't happen to have a lot of stars
of death on you would you like oh you
know what
it's your lucky day [ __ ]
listening just killed it up I still had
it I just fell in his car at about three
months ago my drawer I have a card clip
yes he's like listen you and Joe Rogan
ever want a [ __ ] box at a Jets game
and he gave me his card and it was like
New York Jets definite the perfectly put
then I was like why I showed Rogan yeah
go Rogan if read everything I wrote in
the wall a little walking technique so
is this crazy at this man we were
looking Jets he was about to go to work
he had two cell phones at his [ __ ]
hand but you could tell to do was
somebody nice suit and he stopped what
he was doing he was like hey what about
this one that I told wrong in the end
there I've done some great listen some
weird [ __ ] has happened yeah in the last
five years that even I have been blown
away the family who came up to me in
front of Tom Segura in Portland a family
a mom with the three daughters gone we
listened to a podcast and little girls
like yeah cocksuckin like oh my god was
three weeks ago I went to get this ad
thought I went to do Jitsu I took like a
Puerto Rican shower I wiped down with
that thing I went to the clean Jiu Jitsu
it's always really clean I go to
different places some weeks yeah and I
wonder when I get a hack that was 245
245
I'll [ __ ] you know my head that's it
three yeah I can't come all the way home
it's right by portals I'm right by porno
yeah the lines too long I don't even
have time to wait for a [ __ ] sandwich
and get to the barber I'm watching in
this [ __ ] hundreds of people walking
and I know if between magnolias is dead
all the way up the portals and they're
from pornos for about a half a mile
let's rock yeah in the daytime they got
a Cuban coffee shop and cortadito they
got a pie place together with a Red
Wings shoe yes what's that boy he's
gonna make upside down like a dove
famous don't donut place or something
isla gets her hair cut around there
something I guess so I went over there
and I power try that night no they need
all the [ __ ] Savage you know miss
average what do you think I know I got
15 minutes ago having an egg that is the
first time in there mundo the chick let
a number you know I did I put the area
and help lift the window I'm watching
these white people in Burbank looking
around for who's smoking and I'm blowing
clouds out of the sunroof yeah with the
[ __ ] hand blast and the understand
with the music on like nobody's even in
the car I'm sit down undercover cop you
know me I got tactics I would like the
burglar it's just smoke coming out all
this dough noodle when I got the air on
and then from time to time I open up the
back window and it was riding a corner
it was round the corner so people will
cross the street yeah they'd smell it
right open up the windows bubble
so I leave the windows down after the
joint was done I put it back at the to
the perennial gives you a tube I put it
back in the tube and I put in the door
handle so I walk on I take with me and
dump it on the [ __ ] in the garbage so
I sit in the car like ten minutes
boom it's three o'clock I pull up the
windows the cars or and I spray Febreze
and I walk across the street
I walk to the corner
don't walk out of my car in jaywalk
because burbank that kind of weird yeah
yeah burbank they see you you looking at
your phone you're getting two tickets
don't [ __ ] around and magnolia jack oh
yeah by the 7-eleven no that's where
they kill you
they wait at that light and if you don't
hire you when you're at a light like
this what's the first thing you're doing
your own light well you're fidgety right
yeah you got 12 [ __ ] clicks to the
[ __ ] guy puts his hand up and it
becomes a yellow that means actually got
from the time we're [ __ ] to light
turns yellow to red it's three seconds
so if it says 12 yeah if you could reach
to your left and you go like this in
Burbank yeah and so you just see what
time is and that cop is over there
you're getting pulled on yeah so here I
am
reeking of [ __ ] reefer Ricky I closed
my car door and I walked the proper way
onto the sidewalk and I walked on the
crosswalk well guess who's at the
[ __ ] for now I know that this don't
smell like refill as I smell some
Febreze on me but you always got that
essence of patois when you smoked a
joint in your car just six into your
clothing data with my luck guess who
stands next to me who the [ __ ] do you
think comes it says next to me worse
than a cop especially for guys like me
and you because we understand where
they're coming a kid that's a a mom with
a kid with a stroller with a kid and I
am embarrassed and I feel like the
biggest piece of [ __ ] junkie there is I
really need this mocha join I might know
you're really Joey yeah
really Joey 54 years old and I'm
standing I look up and there's like 92
clicks left like that done I'm not going
anywhere she said next to me she's gonna
stand all the way but I can't she's
gonna comment I would I know it's
[ __ ] two o'clock really Joey you only
gotta be high at [ __ ] two o'clock
do you know that we take ten steps
together she looks over at me and I see
it take a double look by the time we get
for the sidewalk I walk over first to
let her in you know you have to if you
have a child you have to go on that side
where yeah yeah yeah and the whole time
she was looking at manchinga say man I
love you on the German podcast and I
nearly [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants she smelt
the reefer that's why she was smiling oh
do you know how good I felt that's the
first that's a rule that's a redeeming
only a guy like me what anybody who
comes up and says hats and gonna podcast
like the Sun good dick any ideal
situation and this woman was a Burbank
mom yeah I understand you if you
understand I understand you when she
looked at me and smile like wow this is
our bank is the expensive part of the
valley yes that's where when you live
you says Burbank - no idea I didn't know
and and it looked a little small houses
are astronomical price first of all
tomorrow we'll get high and we'll take
it quicker with us see how many houses
are for sale remember take normal
tickets a lot we both saw the house in
Burbank cuz it's a great School District
amazing school it's like the people on
South it's insane where Joey and I live
people are buying houses for two million
dollars that's how good the school
district is and like and like a world in
the cheap of that like we're not living
in the mountains I'm renting cuz I love
it and we look around and we're gonna
find the right [ __ ] thing one day
we're gonna catch somebody asleep yeah
that's it you know that will pray for an
earthquake was the earthquake hits these
[ __ ] run out of healing I
worried before we're building a pool
we're not going anywhere you are going
underground dance man Lee Anne is
[ __ ] happy she's happy she's got the
car she wants she's got the house she
wants the girls are happy they love
their high school their middle school I
think they're gonna go to private school
in Georgia the both gonna get a popsicle
next year why cuz
George is gonna go to high school in
North Hollywood
school wasn't the best high school and I
think there's there's like a zoo magnet
that's really good I don't know I'm only
listening but there's I think Leanne
wants to remember this this private
school that our friends right now you
work very hard he's on the road you're
on every dollar you get the podcast you
got your little TV shows when you were
25 did you ever think that you were
gonna be coming home to support a family
and not blink an eye
well that was 25 you couldn't get a
dollar out of me I think you were
[ __ ] me with my wife and that was my
kids in this family oh that was digging
trenches up we're in we're in London I'm
doing a show in London I'm doing a
podcast in London and I thought the
girls over write and like a sofa bed on
New Zealand air like I flied them over
not not not first-class but in a nice
thing I for I fly over first-class right
I get us a driver we go out to go see
this castle with our friends and we go
up to this little this little Inn on the
10th Thames River on the way to go to
this castle we're going to and the
driver hops out and I'm getting ready to
hop out and Leanne stops me she goes
take two seconds and feel really proud
of yourself I said why she goes your
silly little jokes afforded all of this
like just you coming up with silly jokes
you just and you know it's one of the
things I love about Stanhope it's like I
had that moment where I went like oh
yeah man I just I just have like a I
just I'm I think I'm a good person I
think that's number one that's why I
work you know I'm a good person
but I do I like being silly and I like
giggling I like having a good time like
I don't had a great moment that I
thought not only can I afford to pay for
their lunch break I pay I can afford
this trip off of stand-up also stand-up
comedy and then I called stand-up one
night there's one of my favorite
stand-up stories and it's not a great
story but it's just it's it's nuanced I
think if you're a comic you get it I
call Stanhope I'm uh sit in the man cave
I'm having a cocktail every now and then
we'll just call and just talk for
a little while I just called him up my
go hey what are you doing he's like
sitting out outside the fun house having
a cigarette
having a vodka and our pajamas just
trying to think of some goofs I said
what it goes just thinking of some goofs
you know so like goofs that could be
things 50 sitting around in your pajamas
having a cocktail think of the goofs I
go that is the [ __ ] dream job right
there is being 50 years old
and just sitting around and daydreaming
about something that's silly you know
it's the best the day if you said dream
job is you on Rogen the other day and
you go is changing flavors when I heard
that I was doubled [ __ ] over and I
went that's no Jeff I mean that's for
anyone else that's no job but that's
your job off the [ __ ] I might be too
[ __ ] up to have these balls I'll never
forget that teacher like I farted it's
changing flavor I know what happened I
fought it and it was it took over the
bus for about 20 minutes right and it
was those windows that you had to open
up this one and I never worked and they
had the windows open and they're like
it's changing flavors smelling out the
window right oh my god oh that's
terrible
half the people won't like this yeah
it's settle down five twenty minutes is
about twenty minutes later my stomach is
[ __ ] her pizza on fly I'm like oh my
god I can't thought again a long said I
felt that warm and just slip out of my
head and I was on the outside seat it
was two men per seat and the guy next to
me never even said it's coming from
but paralyzed there were something the
beauty of this was that so that the
first part to go for about 20 minutes
and they were like actually she's
dancing like what is the beauty of it
that like one by one never gone well
flavor was the first one it was death
the first time so now they taking their
hands off and this Blair my mother
forget that they were like two pieces
save the Chile is the front of the bus
they're like all that was so bad were in
the back and some of the guys Jenny
would and you know there was a dude like
nuts
he was like 300 pounds and all he ate it
was mozzarella cheese but he was the
first one they were looking at God rest
his soul you know there was a couple
dudes out a little chubbier you know at
that time I was 140 148 yeah it didn't
really look like it come out of me I
just ain't like a bad steak um yeah over
the heads to the harvest a comes oh my
god and next thing you know I feel that
warming is the funny thing but it was
quiet for two minutes
here's something Oh No people like it no
no open in Austin the teachers smell
that he goes he's changing flavors oh it
was terrible and next you know it was
bad this one was like the thickness of
it I dropped three of them that night
that was the second one the second one
had them going [ __ ] God is like oh no
bus driver please pull over I'm gonna
get sick like that [ __ ] like that type
of [ __ ] and the people saying put puke
in your bags and you need to peel and
I'm sitting there
howling and then oh and Howard I drop
another one like I gave him 20 minute
breather in between the first and the
second one this one was a trembler I hit
him with one and like six minutes later
they got the coral the [ __ ] and they
could not deal with it the chili is
required it's not gonna stop it's not
gonna stop but maybe it's not the but
maybe they they started blame me on the
engine they were blaming in of
everything they could to this day those
people although that was my juicy
[ __ ] they don't know the only reason
why they to say that was me if it's
because the chili is your a fear of
[ __ ] freshmen yeah
they I'm gonna be known if they could
stunk up the bus by all those girls none
of those girls are going to date me so I
couldn't come out and say I'm the guy if
that was just a bus filled with football
guys oh my god I would have pulled my
own finger or they got up and let my
[ __ ] I fly oh that's what happened
the second time he goes oh no he's
changed in flavor but he held on to his
face I'm saying I was on the treadmill
and I grabbed onto both the handlebars
on the side and was doubled over
laughing it was it's funny because it's
like you're watching Joe lose his [ __ ]
Tommy lose his [ __ ] and you're oblivious
to the fact that it's that funny
I took the comic to bram when I was
booking Brian on Wednesday nights
Vinny light bulbs a cave and he Coppola
moved to North Hollywood and I bumped
into him when I asked if he had a cake
in my game and in front of any I told
the story about that place and Tennessee
with it I went on stage and the chick
was said the husband was oh yeah
we in this you went back in you told me
that started one night but not on the
podcast just talking like who does that
happen to Manley harmless trouble goes
to Knoxville comedians this I die like
that club I'd never been to that club
but I've seen it cuz it a new club no
the oh the old one the one that was of
that white box or that box this was the
I was there was in the hotel it belonged
to half okay it was a to later as a
fireman half from Charlotte yeah yeah I
don't know that kind of those guys yet
creative entertainment little brothers
or something I don't know I don't know
what the deal was the deal when I moved
that way there was a manager here that I
signed with and had just left creative
yeah
they were huge because they had carrot
top they were he would sell isn't it
yeah he was huge at that time that just
shot the movie and the three guys were
like we can't fight over carrot top so
it's just split them three ways and with
a part you know they got all really
because there was three guys they than
one of them so we should manager Minh
and others of course well cuz it's three
guys they want the big deal the big deal
on about like getting this career off
the ground
you don't Bert you said some interesting
Joe Rogan has been saying it for 20 is
Ralphy said it to me today when I spoke
with him
and I realized it's a few years ago with
stand-up comics I was a mediocre
stand-up comic so I started this podcast
mediocre at best
I was a funny guy that didn't know how
to organize anything and I felt
listening to rogue and I started going
back for the timely spill six years I've
been back five years whatever it is I
started watching the Li and Sebastian
and run white and chappal and you know I
remember going to Columbus the first
time for Justin and just eating a bag of
dicks the whole weekend I hate it book
me for years true and I'm like I know
why cuz I ate a bag of text I wasn't
really headlining now we got it down now
it all back together at the same time
the stand-up perform the the [ __ ]
technique now you have UI that this
aspect to it you add the aspect of
coming out to a podcast telling your
point of view about something but at the
same time explaining why you're saying
that point of view you lived it you have
to give it a chance to let it breathe
for a few days
yeah you can make assumptions you know
it's like what happened today shot the
[ __ ] world
I mean shockingly I had just gotten some
weed I put it in front of the heater to
drive I left in front of the heat of the
dry and I went to take mercy swimming
and while I'm sitting there watching
Mercy's from one like I forgot to take
the heater off so while they were
showering getting dressed I ran home
they either was off I was so high forgot
I [ __ ] turned it off but as I was
walking out Lee called me and said that
John Jones have been yeah whatever with
the steroids it was a kick for my
[ __ ] stomach I mean it was a kick to
my [ __ ] stomach you know I went back
my wife was putting mercy in the car I
gotta tell you something when you're
gonna be in and I believe this you know
we're both your friends
yeah we both believe something you know
and I was disappointed and my wife
couldn't [ __ ] believe it you know she
was like how could this happen then we
would eat and a friend called and she's
would've just going on she's like I
finally believed in bubble pop and you
know he sent his [ __ ] to an iceberg
I'll give you two a million dollars at
me when I was in my twenties I was gonna
show up at six o'clock in the morning
someone I hope you don't really believe
that yeah I really hope that that when I
was 27 if you gave me $20,000 and said I
had to be somewhere in the morning
be there I wouldn't be there oh my
twenties were [ __ ] disaster
I don't know about you Lee was a little
bit more controlled he took it he didn't
take as many chances
there's some people I went crazy like
you look looking at me from what I did
like this time I've done uh honey I
would never thought I would do that
stuff I don't like the acid yeah that
stuff and then like stand up and not
though life is an experienced man it's
so weird nothing happens to you do it
you know yeah like you could sit there
and read all the books you want about
scumbags who did this and you're buying
it for that [ __ ]
meanwhile you're sitting there reading
about somebody else's [ __ ] life you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know I we were talking
about the idea where we grew up in the
areas where he grew up and I'd like to
figure out how many people actually left
our area when I came down honey
no man came from they either went to
Miami and when they do vacation they go
to Miami or Atlantic so that's the big
weekend the Asia uh some of them left
firm I wouldn't have left if I had
family oh I would have never left if I
had family I had no family I had a
chance to [ __ ] get up and gut one
watch what was going on I stand up got
me to leave I was like I can't do
stand-up in Florida I was just end up
staying to Florida I'll be I'll be funny
I'll get a radio gig on just and Florida
like I'll never leave and I won't be
ever run my own radio show cuz I don't
have that kind of interest in that I'll
just be a third bike of God I'd I would
end up so [ __ ] hacky and thank God I
laughed you're lucky cuz the warrants
got me to leave really the warrants a
couple loansharks had no she don't had
no [ __ ] clue then I left made it out
of there and then nobody said nothing I
went back and got more and got green I
started [ __ ] around with drug dealers
yeah and friends and [ __ ] drug deals
and then I had a [ __ ] leave and I'm
happy I did I love where we telling go
to San Francisco the second day it
destroys me
will you have a disaster for watch one I
went to I went at first I went to basalt
and then I lived in basalt from one and
a half and we were gonna give up the
house and me and my buddy from Jersey
moved to an apartment in Snowmass and we
were there for a while and then I
started burglarizing the businesses and
wrote drug dealers in the area and storm
out anything I thought to me and I came
back to Jersey like it's by the way for
no one who's ever been to Aspen or Aspen
it's such a small community please it
was terrible terrible tally burglarizing
I'm ashamed of all hundred people I
still remember Christmas Eve 1984 that
was nautical I had said for business
eisenberg more for businesses
burglarized on Christmas Eve you know
what that was what me being at home
feeling sorry for myself
I had a little package of coke in my
pocket I don't let me go for a [ __ ]
walk and see use that [ __ ] go for a
walk I know there's the only bar that's
open on Christmas Eve filled with losers
I'll never forget that one guy in the
bongo that I forget this is clear as day
and a friend of mine took a bottle shake
it up his shadow that the guy like
what's the [ __ ] is wrong with you right
let's set the tone for tonight
in those days they used to drink
Southern Comfort orange juice it's
called a tequila sunrise oh no no no no
it's called a southern sunrise with you
an American bottle you know I have had
that drink I had that drink one time I
had it at malleus at this time that was
my drink I was 19 maybe 20 and I do
listen
Homa be honest with you all the things I
didn't like about drinking was you come
to me on the Tuesday languor Joey I got
enough money for an 8-ball let's they go
right I go you know when I go [ __ ]
yourself give me a southern comfort
give me a second kind of southern
comfort give me a third song and
fountain out the way they would probably
live I would be a regular guy and in
those days I would have three or four
southern comfort
and I became [ __ ] Coco yeah I would
leave there like a [ __ ] Savage and I
would have to rob something like I would
have to Rob kicking the door
something yeah it was crazy hello
there's one night I left this [ __ ]
place it was like 2:00 in the morning
it's [ __ ] Christmas I got no
girlfriend I lived with a guy he's got a
girlfriend a girl I'm gonna go back and
finish this package in my pocket I don't
let me see what the [ __ ] hold on I
like kicked in like four doors and
finally one door I found the safe you
know I didn't think was safe to go and
those the safe to go oh and those days
safer we go he described his hey man
walk out on a [ __ ] one of those carts
oh that's crazy
and you take it home and bang on it for
three hours like you know what you're
doing then finally got a call around for
a week and he gonna go back and I got a
guy who knows how to have a blow torch
with a shunt and it with uh slippery
fingers Lee leave your sleep no I can't
believe what I'm hearing
hey Lee how do you like don't worry
about the cops coming when I was a kid I
watched him movie called thief yeah I
was a headed [ __ ] molded me so I
wanted to be a full-time teeth so for a
while I'm in my bra well I'm Rob Martin
the [ __ ] you know I did it
Hal I [ __ ] got those suction cups I
thought I was [ __ ] the Pink Panther I
got suction cups like an idiot right
Christ you ready for this yeah cuz you
know me I was Johnny mafia you've
learned to be a burglar on move from
movies you just like took all their
tricks huh you took all the tricks from
movie movie burglars oh my god that's
what you did put on [ __ ] leave you
are I the thief you are the highest I've
ever seen you we having real we got it
we're still doing the second half of the
park guys we need some more stars
Christian going three hours only should
program I have to work out in the
morning let me tell you something I
watch this movie oh honey the thief with
James Caan
1981 you never saw this day huh
just once in our shrine you go home and
tuck Ain you gotta watch it just put it
up what what scene click it up on the
[ __ ] thing hey what was the deal with
Ellen 1000 earth is she Kristin
Chenoweth's no no no no no no no
absolutely you're horrible don't you
things really what you only 6th only
it's [ __ ] the planet I win one six
double G's you gave me like eight honey
like 12 of course night that that was a
mm just what we're doing will you tell
you something allotted to the Navy
trying if I watch this movie and then I
went back to Jersey and my friend turned
me on to his friend and he used to get
me jobs to go to
warehouses in case the joints up and let
him know where the safe was is she like
no thief English subtitles all that hold
up was there no Presley the thief James
cut with capital of this place my
worries a little bit will be the first
grade are they gone they go not just
James Caan yeah all right click on to
badass nobody ever saw this movie that
one like Todd's one us I'm gonna show
you something else too guys you don't
learn something watching this thing you
know I don't show you no [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait I've been rocking your
world all week
this is what's his name they got a
delivery or something he said I think
what my name is Frank and that's
[ __ ]
what is this is Joe gags 185,000 my
money we had this problem no problem
what are you talking about he was moving
my merchandise so the money in his
pocket when he went out the window
is my money this is a plating company
what are you telling me this [ __ ] [ __ ] I
want my money
Hey I don't know what you're talking
about mr. Frank
Lyla whatever some guy died yes your
steak goes the probate take it to
probate court what do you bug me with
this
I come here to discuss a piece of
business with you
what are you gonna do you gonna tell me
fairytales hey you know [ __ ] you slick
somebody knows you what are you crazy or
what I don't know you I don't know some
clown name gags go see what you gotta do
get out of here call get the [ __ ] outta
here
oh all right all right
oh hey do what he says do what he says
lay down right put your hands on your
head spread your legs
now hey oh you're goof look at the wall
I am the last guy in the world that you
want to [ __ ] with
you found my money on gigs let us
pretend you don't know whose money it is
that's right for Christ's sakes I don't
know you are three hours we'll call to
set a meet you will pay me my money
one hundred and eighty five thousand
dollars
[Music]
there's how the movie starts that time
movies it didn't hit the country they
came out on HBO Wow it was on the same
month as the Raging Bull and Hollywood
nice click on tonight one Scene unders
you go all the way the thing all right
but the other one the other direct dad
click onto that this movie will blow
your [ __ ] mind
and he also who who directed this leak
you know directed this together did
Miami Vice he's big-time he directed
heat all he did what he wrote heat was
rewrite this nobody saw it
wait Michael man my command this is it
[Music]
he released this an 81 nobody saw
get
[Music]
you remember my name now I'm killing
nothing since the police depart
doesn't that hide too many Puerto Ricans
[ __ ] I'm Italian I'm pleased to meet
you a [ __ ] okay you're a real stand-up
guy you got a mouth you can take a
trimmin you could make things easy for
everybody but no you got to be a goof
you're real good no balance strictly
professional
I'd probably like you like to go to the
track ballgames stuff like that you know
Frank there's ways of doing things that
round off the corners make life easy for
everybody what's wrong with that there's
plenty to go around we know what you
take down we know you got something
major coming down soon but no you gotta
come on like a stiff prick who the [ __ ]
do you think you are what's the matter
with you you've got something to say
you're you waiting for me to ask you to
dance it never occurred to you to try to
work for a living
take down your own scores okay [ __ ] this
guy tell yourself I'm gonna be on your
ass so much you're gonna get careless
and gonna be in that place next
is the last place that you want to be
because no matter what happens I will
never ever take a pinch from a greasy
[ __ ] like you Don you guys will
get the Sham to watch this movie
from beginning that I'll watch it now
who's it who are whose it the cast I
think I feel like I know the cast did
cast is death
the cast is Belushi's brother and you
wait for this one yeah
the country was the singer go back to
sea for a second there cuz and the guys
that lay down on the floor when he told
them go back to scenes like scenes from
the YouTube that you had before he knows
one of those guys that lays down Dennis
Farina exactly that was that's who it
was how think it was first movies no no
not the guy that shakes him down and he
calls the Puerto Rican to know that [ __ ]
who's that he's an actor that was around
for that I think he did a couple
episodes of Miami Vice but he was
basically in a TV show that Michael Mann
did called crime story what year was
this which one am I looking at 1981 the
thief James Caan okay keep going onto
that James Caan keeps growing Willie
Nelson
yeah Willie though James Belushi yeah
keep going
Dennis Farina scroll down we for love of
Christ hold on she goes the ending
ending of confrontation
you see it up there right in front a lot
more up more right there the legs from
there you go your [ __ ] honey ma the
confrontation there you go
I'm giving you some good [ __ ] scenes
here this movie guys drove me [ __ ]
crazy I was done I wasn't gonna go to
college I wasn't gonna do nothing with
my life I wasn't giving good and figure
out how to open up safes for 11
yeah this is one of movies from the 80s
the problem movies from the eighties is
it takes a long time to get to where
you're going yeah okay now at this time
this guy sitting on the couch was big
from Hill Street Blues this is you know
you ever see those movies that you look
and you know ha that's an easy script I
could have wrote that yeah this is one
of those scripts that you know like this
was a pretty good [ __ ] script the
[ __ ] the way they were oh you could
just tell that guy who's that guy right
there
he was anything shot in Chicago they
used this well under that guy these are
all Chicago actors all those movies
they'd be stepping off crew the blue
oval is that a the Breakfast Club all
those movies there was the little
brother the Blues Brothers oh wow that's
I would definitely thought I wouldn't
know that but you know sometimes you
gotta have people in the head
forget the mother she's like you know
what I don't know nothing I don't know
no I'm not gonna call nobody I wanted on
that understand City and watch my
novella he's gone
yes movie had some scenes that he liked
and Bertie was on every night either is
the same water HBO didn't have a lot of
money in 1982 this is an HBO movie this
was a movie that I first saw on HBO oh
wow and I first wanted seen this in a
trio like january/february ready - it
was on every night followed by Raging
Bull or Hollywood nights or they would
flip flop so every night I'd get home
the nights I would do blow I get home
and me and my brother would walk down
the pad mark but like 10 bucks shoplift
10 bucks worth - stop go home make
milkshakes in the sandwich can watch
this
[Music]
he's walking down hauling well they gun
thank you I forgot the narrated I don't
know I thought they could see it but
unless you're home watch that you can't
see Danny all you need to know is this
witness enter we get thumb up your
[ __ ] ass watching preseason football
watch a film that's a classic 1981 the
thief James Caan Tuesday Weld Willie
Nelson and Belushi's brother and I gotta
taste some Belushi's brothers [ __ ]
goodness
I saw about a point one time and I was
gonna say some tongue but I said you
know what I opened my mouth to grandpa's
always got a gun
[Music]
all right now fast-forward into him
walking outside
[Music]
right then take a right back like this
guy just wakes up he comes out of his
[ __ ] coconut he shoots him first
[Music]
[Applause]
I like music oh yeah this is tangerine
Dream's it will [ __ ] hot in the 80s
70s look at my boy look at James ton
shooting like a mutt look at that is for
Rinas first movie there you go that
little history for you [ __ ] I
think code of silence was the second
movie with [ __ ] Chuck Norris who the
[ __ ] to get dealing with birth
crashing some [ __ ] obviously Dennis
Farina beautiful head of hair oh god
yeah
oh no he's on breasts on a [ __ ]
around James contract
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah Michael Mann was thinking of doing
apart to this but he just rewrote in
trying to defeat
[Music]
into the hedges for those first death my
movie
[Music]
if I ever have to do a top 10 movie
podcast this will be in the top 10 and
I'll blow your [ __ ] mind throughout
this news
Oh both we best budget be an investment
this guy came prepared back from he was
ready for war this [ __ ] zombie
Farina
listen dog he paid his wife to leave the
baby to leave he blew up all his
businesses he became a zombie he has a
suitcase in the back of that car with
cash and he's going somewhere too
[ __ ] high he's done
he was robbing for herself making a
great living he got in bed with some
[ __ ] jerk-offs they tried to rob him
he said I'm getting my money from him
they got pissed off and that's the end
of the movie he walks away solo like
Michael Jackson in 77 years and I like
that jib shop listen for you [ __ ]
savages I will be at the Ontario improv
Thursday Friday and Saturday my brother
here mr. Bert Kreischer will be and I'd
stand up live got it in Phoenix Thursday
Friday Saturday first show Thursday 8
o'clock listen that's the best show of
the night you're gonna show up you know
smoke a couple key salutes and we do a
little extra time because we're trying
to find the [ __ ] right combination
for the night Friday early I'll be
sensational Friday late it'll be
sensational then again if you want to be
a Momo watch the fire and not come on
down either [ __ ] stand-up live in
Phoenix or Ontario improv in the Ontario
Mills Mall and hang out with your
[ __ ] uncle Joey take a chance
Columbus dinner right that's how we're
doing it before I leave I just want to
mention one thing to you [ __ ] savages
that's very important you want to look
good and your underwear and be
comfortable right but the perfect
balance is hard to find don't sacrifice
style or comfort check out Mia nice calm
and find the best pair underwear in the
world me and these will be the most
comfortable pair on the way your ever
own made from sustainable source
naturally soft fabric that is three
times softer than cotton ultimate feels
limitation they're the ultimate feel
good on these for when you want to feel
naked but not be naked you know I'm
saying for the fellas beyond these
diamonds same pouch cradle your jewels
and give your stuff to supporting needs
without feeling too tight the ladies
will love the soft eco-friendly fabric
so soft in touchable you get what I'm
talking about 100% satisfaction
guarantee they guarantee you'll love the
undies
or your money back alright right now me
undies
we offer our listeners the family get
20% off your first pair and free
shipping and the undies are so sure you
love the underwear they even offer 100%
satisfaction guarantee that you'll love
it you wanted a pair if you don't love
the first pair you get a full refund
it's that easy it's a no-brainer to try
20% off free shipping
hundred-percent guarantee what the hell
are you waiting for to get you 20% off
free shipping a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed ready write this
down
don't even write this down do it right
now me on these comm slash Joey that's
me on these dot-com slash Joey this is a
limited time only so what the hell are
you waiting for start wearing the best
underwear of your life
hey they changed my life I went to
jujitsu they keep my nutsack nice and
cozy in case I bump into a victim on the
way home you don't saying it's time to
let them me undies change yours go to me
on these comm slash Joey
right now I'm wrong I got you here
listen he rolled up you can't live in
your mom's basement no more right you
trying to be a [ __ ] savage and you
know what I'm trying to say to you is
this plain and simple did you know the
depending on where you get your mortgage
you could save $20,000 or more but 80%
of people only get one mortgage offer
and if you just go to your bank chances
are you'll get ripped off slash screwed
you're following me Lending Tree doesn't
want that to happen
here's the thing the average Lending
Tree customer can save twenty thousand
dollars over the life of their loan
that's just the average half of that
customers could save even more whether
you're looking for a new mortgage or
refinance or home equity loan Lending
Tree is the only place when you'll get
five real offers from America's top
lenders
they're side by side for free it only
takes three minutes okay if I shopping
for flights online only you're shopping
for the best mortgage office for you
rates always go up and down but
regardless of what happens what what's
happening with the rates you can always
get the Rick right offer for you which
is the most important thing with Lending
Tree dot-com are you sure you have the
best deal let's find out right what's
gonna take you three minutes find out
how much you could save today
Lending three.com slash Church today
right now take a chance Columbus dead
that's lending three.com slash Church
again Lending Tree dot-com slash Church
I'm gonna save you some money go to
right now London three.com slash Church
Lending Tree LLC nmls number one 136
terms and conditions apply
I want to thank Lending Tree I want to
thank me on this
I want to thank on it I don't want to
thank my main man Bert Kreischer for
coming in I love you Jill a bottle and
couple stars a knife we got a little
prep because it's a [ __ ] professional
and that's how we do it
I'll see you [ __ ] in Ontario
and Bert Kreischer I'll see you at
stand-up live in Phoenix I love you
[ __ ] are all my heart
stay black have a great weekend thank
you very much for listening
you [ __ ] savages
you
you